Still no main event for a mess.
Gregor?
No.
Four three,
two,
one
boo Ya,
Ya know,
main event from Madison Square Garden.
So far the rumors were John Jones and Gustafson.
I Dunno.
I Dunno why that hasn't materialized or they just waiting till announce it till
after the whole Connor could beep thing.
Why would they do that?
I think if they announced something that's gotta be this weekend,
I mean we're,
what isn't it November 3rd or something?
It's soon.
So it's a month.
Pursued my literally a month.
Today's the third right second.
Today's the second.
Yeah.
Fuck man,
that ain't good.
I,
yeah,
maybe they just don't want to steal any shine from the Connor could beat,
but I don't know man.
I just don't have a card yet.
I think they were banking on Jones to for that main event.
It's been tricky to fill that slot.
But also why not have,
if,
if you're going to do this,
why not announce Nate Diaz does import is your main event.
That's a great main event.
I can ride with that.
And then advanced,
then announced John Jones and Gus van or John Jones and Cain if you want to,
but the main event is to be announced versus to be determined.
The weirdest made a bit of everything.
I've never seen a fucking paper view.
I'm a month out that says to be announced versus to be determined in the main
event.
I mean they have somebody booked and then the not an opponent form and a nodding
announcing it or is it just like decided to just be funny and write both?
That's a very good point.
Just a good point.
Very good point.
I would say they have no idea.
I think you just nailed the baby.
I think they have a guy that they want to fight.
Another guy I had heard a,
actually I heard from you
tried to do John Jones versus cane.
That was the rumor mill.
That little Birdie told me.
Yeah,
that would be,
I'm all over that.
I would be all over that car.
It's actually better than this weekend's card style benders fighting Derek
Brunson.
That's a great fight sleeper.
That's the sleeper on that card right there.
You got Luke Rockhold,
Chris Weidman.
Ooh,
that's a good fight to gray David branching.
Where is Rockpool Weidman on there?
The bottom middle,
but they're not in order yet.
Oh,
what?
This thing's all over the place.
Puzzle.
The guy who runs the UFC website took the month off.
Rockhold versus Weidman.
Very interesting that listen,
gay guard Musashi was that.
That guy is the fucking sleeper of the hundred 95 pound division.
The fact that he went over to Bella tour,
very fucking fascinating to me.
He just rec Roy MacDonald completely rectums type to watch.
Roy should not be fighting at 185 pounds,
especially against the guys fought at two oh five he's held titles at two Oh
five I agree.
And especially a guy in Gig harbor,
we saucy who's just as talented just as skill.
Soon waving guns might be better in some other aspects.
Then when you go skill for skill,
then size comes into play and you saw how that pans out.
Crush.
It says
from Saas has a giant Dick.
How would he know who was in the sauna next to him?
Oh,
that makes sense though.
You know what is a giant,
she has that big Dick Energy.
He like he did.
He just carries himself like a straight bad-ass the knee,
like nothing really gets them going.
You know why?
Because there's a giant Dick giant Dick.
You know what,
Burt Burt's probably ride on this.
God,
this makes sense.
You're brilliant.
Bert Kreischer while he it,
I mean it's not even like you figured it out.
I mean he,
he's got like eye witness.
He's seen that there is in the room.
Nothing's ever made more sense than that.
He got hot cedar box with a big old sweaty Dick Dude that gay guard Amsterdam
did.
Everyone's like,
how come he doesn't get more emotional cause he the fattest stick and they're
horrible.
He swore it was bigger than his fucking water bottle
water bottle.
He goes,
dude,
I'm telling you
it was giant.
I'm like,
wow.
All right,
that makes sense man.
It does make a lot of sense.
Yeah,
but gay guide me Sassy not now bell tours in his string kind of predicament
because they have that welterweight terminate going on.
Now you have your champion who's going to enter the tournament as the title
holder in the first round supposed to fight John Fitch who isn't an easy fight,
but he just coming off a loss and got destroyed.
And also it looks like you had some no's damage,
which was his issue before.
Yeah,
his nose had been fucked up for a long time and you know,
he decided to take a whole year off just to try to fix his nose.
Just try to let it heal.
That's serious.
Whole year off.
I mean you think about it,
that was like part of the delay in his initial fight in tour was that he left
the UFC.
You know his nose got smashed in the Robbie Lawler fight.
I mean it was hard to watch.
Remember when he was in agony on the ground cause his nose just shattered.
They said every time we get to hit it just go white like sparks.
He couldn't see anything.
It was a bad injury.
He said there is one of the best fights of all time by the one that grades one
of the greatest fights.
He earned that shit.
Yeah.
But now,
uh,
with Rory,
you know what's sad too,
and that's happened to me.
It's happened to some other fighters.
I'm sure Roy,
he goes,
I just didn't get it.
I just didn't feel like fighting.
I did.
I was in,
wasn't in the zone,
just didn't feel like fighting Gig army saucy that night.
Knowing Gay Guard saucy,
who's who,
he doesn't get enough recognition.
How good that he,
he is absolute monster.
You've got to think about all the guys that he's beaten.
Oh,
he's on like a six or seven fight win streak,
which includes Chris Weidman.
Vito Belfort,
Talus latest,
um,
uhW,
who's the guy in Beltour,
the former champion.
Sheila Manco.
Uh,
sh yeah,
I was getting,
I always call,
I won't call him shift.
Chanko that's fucked up.
That's the girl
that he's an absolute nightmare.
A monster.
He's a monster.
I'm surprised the UFC let them go now when I say let them go,
just didn't matches his contract,
you know,
cause belter probably offered more and they're like,
oh,
we're good.
Yeah.
You'll see.
Could use them right now.
Maybe five.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
it's like they had Yoel Romero,
they've got Robert Whitaker was a champ.
They've got so much going on at one 85 but gay guard might be the best.
I mean,
he's certainly in the running.
If you looked at it objectively,
it's entirely possible if he's not number one,
he's he's number two,
top three e's.
Number three.
Yeah,
but also you look at his fight.
If him and Robert Whitaker would a fight,
that's not an easy pick them file.
You would have to be like,
damn,
that's a fucking fight.
You might favorite cake art.
You don't know how big and long and scrappy person,
listen,
Robert Whitaker is a monster.
He's phenomenal.
I mean,
but so it was Mu Saucy,
so it was Musashi and we saucy has a full game man.
His crown game is phenomenal and the biggest dick in the division,
giant Dick.
There's stuff that has to be taken into consideration at all.
This might be now eos.
I bet it's bigger.
No Way.
I bet it's no bro.
He doesn't care.
That energy is too aggressive.
What's,
yeah,
when you're that aggressive,
you don't have that fat.
He looks like that and doesn't have a big Dick.
I don't know,
Dude.
See Batman,
Batman,
the comic drew a Dick and he's,
that's Batman.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Batman has a dick now.
That's the new comic.
There's like this new,
like kind of x rated Batman they're coming out with and they show Batman's Dick.
That's how I pictured.
This isn't even Yoel Romero,
millennials.
These are just fucking millennials that think they're going to rewrite history
there.
Make an iron man a woman.
They're crazy.
Yeah.
It's just people are out of their fucking mind.
Captain America's now a woman.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm just saying iron man's probably gay.
Everyone's,
it's this,
there's a weird revolution right now in comics because,
uh,
they're trying to,
sort of social justice,
warrior up all the comedy,
all the comic books.
What do you laugh at?
That it is true.
It is true.
All cogans.
Uh,
I'll get this DC comics,
sorry for showing everyone that man's penis.
That's y'all.
Romil Bro.
Yo,
it's real.
That's not real.
So that's a comic book and it's a comic book.
That's by the way,
was created in like,
what was,
let's just take a guess.
When Batman was created,
I'm going to guess like 1940 when he thinks super old school,
1940 1950s I can't rewrite Batman's Dick and 2018 the guy drawing it,
I didn't have the biggest day.
Kelly is tiny little and just mad,
but maybe he thought that was massive.
Probably thought was the biggest dick he's ever seen.
He had a scared to watch porn and then,
and they got backlash and he's like,
what the fuck at this was a big cock and was like,
no dude,
I for Batman's Batman,
you pray that mans the weirdest superhero ever because he's basically just a
rich guy.
But he's Ilan Musk well on steroids and can fight.
He's,
he must,
yeah,
basically that's what he is with a bunch of stuff.
No special skills,
but he knows how to fight,
but he doesn't have any superpower,
just nothing.
He's still rich,
dude.
That's why I got angry at that Batman versus superman.
Superman would.
First of all,
he moves so fast he could make the earth spin backwards and reverse time to his
lasers in his eyes for gut.
There's no vibe
pseudo to cryptonite.
Superman would fuck him up before you even got the suit on him to files Lex
Luthor Valliant like the adversary for him.
That's not okay.
He just,
his board,
it keeps that to the round like a side piece.
Let's have some fun,
dude.
He's like,
let this guy pertains kicking my ass.
Venom drops this weekend.
Tom Hardy.
You know what?
Maybe I'm just a Debbie Downer,
but I don't,
I don't know.
It looks all right to me and I love when I love Tom Hardy to venom is like on
evil Spiderman.
Like what is that?
He's like Spiderman.
It's alien.
It's an alien.
It's an alien element.
They grabbed someone's body.
That merchants with his body.
Yeah,
and he's evil.
I don't know.
Fuck your kids today.
I know.
I know,
man.
I know.
I mean,
I guess it's better than remaking the Hawk for the 98th time.
I'll take it.
I mean,
how many Spiderman's are there now?
It's like 80 Spiderman.
Whenever Spiderman starts making some money,
they go like,
Nah,
player.
We got,
I need bro.
We got a new one.
Tobey Maguire is my Spiderman.
Spiderman.
Is anyone else?
Fuck you.
Yeah.
That's the real Spiderman.
Hell yeah.
He keep k they had two new ones since him.
Right.
What is it that you've been to one guy that never even got any traction?
Holland.
Who fucks Tom Hall.
Sorry Tom.
They wanted to make sure your wonderful,
they want to make Donald Glover splatter majors.
I think he's the voice in this cartoon they just announced today.
This comes out this into the spider first get stunning new trailer.
Head of New York comic con.
I was talking to Chris Pratt about comicon.
What'd he say?
You know,
cause he's got to go there for guardians of the galaxy and he's probably like
fun,
tough.
He's like,
he goes,
hi,
I'm in the middle of this place.
And I just said to myself,
I don't belong here.
Yeah.
It's a different vibe.
He is the nicest guy.
He goes to a bunch of UFC events.
Yeah.
He's been to one.
It was only at one.
Is that where you talked to him at the fucking,
he came hunting with us and Utah.
Oh,
nice.
Yeah.
Let's go fucking nicest guy.
Like so normal around everybody.
Good Hunter.
Yeah.
Real good.
Good Archer.
And people forget.
He started off as a comedian actor.
Like he was like the funny guy.
What was that show?
He was on the office.
Parks and parks.
Pudgy.
Yeah.
Back then.
Now he's all jacked and it weird tone was like,
dude,
you're going to be the next action here.
And he's like,
what?
Here's a boat load of let's do that.
I don't even think it was that.
I think he just lost the weight and everybody went,
Oh,
you know,
he was a wrestler in high school and college.
Was He really a college?
Yeah.
Good wrestler.
He took,
I cannot assault.
I saw him wrestling with Nogueira.
Yeah,
he actually looked pretty good.
Who's wrestling with Nogueira?
Yeah,
there's video of him wrestling the guy.
Yeah.
And I was like,
damn,
that dude knows what he's doing.
I,
I had no idea.
He was a,
you know,
wrestling,
I squat on a farm in a like outside of Seattle and raises animals and I actually
has like a farm,
like a,
a real,
um,
I think the way that co just like very humane,
ethical treatment of the animals.
Like the animals are all like super adjusted to human beings.
And then when they whack them,
they just take them into a room and put one in their brain and he does it.
Or this is just his crate.
It's him and Nogueira.
Yeah.
Linked to this,
but for,
you know,
I had no idea.
I just thought he was a normal actor.
Like mom this time when you watch actors,
like look at this bullshit.
Yeah,
no,
he's at his set up everything.
Yeah.
Now he knows how to wrestle.
He wrestled in college and in high school.
Well,
you know,
if he's feeling Frisky,
the UFC is looking at fighters these days.
I don't know what he's looking at paying that guy.
That guy's making $20 million a movie.
How the fuck are you going to pay him for that?
We'll figure it out that star.
Lord,
Bro,
I know.
Come up with your own whiskey row.
Who's someone else besides Star-Lord too?
What else?
What other movies do?
Keith garland galaxy drastic park.
[inaudible] park tease the tightness.
Come on man.
Dinosaur Wrangler.
Jurassic Park.
He,
yeah,
and he,
here's the thing,
he came in like,
you know,
there was already Jurassic Park before and then he came in with a new drastic,
with the hotness with no hiccups.
Zl One was like bullshit with this new Jurassic Park,
there was nothing got better.
Yeah.
It got bad over the animation got better to animation.
Dinosaurs got super legit.
I haven't seen the newest one that fucking bad as it good.
Loved it.
Freaked my kid out though.
Little one had buried her head in my armpit.
Some of the scenes.
Yeah,
it was fucking,
things are scary.
Shit.
Legit.
They look real.
The re do you,
you know the redoing the dress park ride at universal to Redo it.
Yeah.
They shit is whack as fuck.
That's just that.
T racks like her.
No.
The Guy was taught here to interview.
The guy's like,
no,
we're redoing it with all the new dinosaurs.
Everything.
Yeah.
There's some good shit at universal.
And then there's some stuff that you're like,
what old school?
Well,
you know,
it's bad ass.
The Harry Potter ride,
if you take a little man to the Harry Potter ride,
it's not picking up still.
He's only two and a half.
That's right.
I think you have to be like 40 inches or some shit.
But the Jurassic,
the Jurassic Park ride is whack.
You know what's great?
The Simpsons sentences delve.
I've done.
It's hilarious.
It's great.
That's a great ride,
dude.
I as a grown ass men just by got a babysitter for my kid and me and my girl went
to six flags.
Oh Dude.
Six flags is bad ass.
So much fun.
You know what?
Surprisingly good.
Knott's berry farms it.
Uh,
it's very old school.
A little vintage.
Some of the fucking rides are amazing to me.
They're a little,
the little suspect like a year ago,
like the suspect,
like they might break.
Yeah,
like the wood roller goes from like really
rapidly.
Like when's the last time?
So in check,
this guy,
dad didn't go on that one,
but I went on one where you're sitting in your seat like this,
right?
And then you go like this clink.
He goes up so your back,
like if you fell,
you would fall right on your balance over and then you get to the top and you
pause and then they turn you like this and it is.
Yeah,
it was the best rollercoasters I've ever been on knots,
skeptical,
Hipaa us because when he get there,
their whole theme is Charlie Brown.
It's like who the fuck's watching Charlie Brown these days?
Everyone has to this Spiderman,
marvel.
Disney would make you,
they get Charlie Brown.
I'm like kids like who the fuck is?
Notice Charlie Brown.
It was all like there's a wild west theme area.
Oh,
it's random ass shit.
But they're,
their main slogan is Charlie Brown.
Well,
we had a good time.
Good time,
man.
You know what a,
I'll tell you what though.
All overall best ride I've ever been on 100% is Disney world.
The Jurassic not to dress apart.
The avatar ride,
the Avatar ride in Orlando.
All right.
It's called flights of passage.
I think it is.
Dude bought beyond the greatest ride ever.
It's all virtual reality.
You climb into like a chair,
like you're on a motorcycle,
it pushes against your back and you settle into this thing and then you put
these goggles on with this headset thing on and you're in full virtual reality
and this is it.
And you,
the listener,
this is the one where you're on the boat.
There's two actual avatar rides.
This one's pretty dope too.
That looks legit.
It looks like Avatar world.
Yeah,
this one.
That's pretty dope too.
That one.
You're on a boat like pirates of the Caribbean.
Yeah.
This is it.
I liked the boat.
The boat's pretty bad ass.
But this one,
you're flying in full virtual reality while you're riding on the back of one of
those drag and things.
I mean,
I've seen better graphics on,
but no,
no,
no.
And what you're just not getting isn't doing it.
Know when you're there.
Yeah.
They filmed their screen.
They're not even filming this scream in three d.
Right.
So he's just using his cell phone.
That's why it looks all blurry is a long line.
Long as shit,
as long as shit.
And then while you're doing it,
like you get breezes in your face and you smell things,
it's fucking incredible,
man.
It feels real.
It's the best ride I've ever been on by far.
Like I got it.
I've been on some dope rods.
That's Numero Uno with a bullet by far.
By far.
Hello?
Yeah,
I did it two times in a row,
dude.
I'm a sucker for the,
I'm old school.
I like the haunted mansion.
Battered old school lens man.
And then they put in a,
um,
what is it,
a nightmare.
Before Christmas.
Yeah.
Jack.
Yeah,
right around around Halloween time.
Yeah.
I love Halloween.
I love it.
Yeah.
Have you taken him to Disneyland yet?
Oh yeah.
Season Pass.
Oh,
that's the shit,
right?
I feel like he's getting spoiled because,
you know,
when I'm working in my girl,
I take him and her friends and they go,
he's going when he's not in school,
he's in school now,
but two times a week.
Oh yeah.
They go just to chill,
a little dewy screwed when it gets old.
And I know that is so spoiled.
It was such a big deal when I was a kid.
It was such a big deal.
You go with Joey Diaz and Joey's family.
Did you go with Joey Now Sandy?
Oh that's right.
Anyway.
Yeah,
that's gotta be a trip.
Yeah.
Fun.
Disneyland's when you have kids becomes a totally different thing.
It's a special place.
Yeah.
I was like,
before I had kids,
I'm not going to fuck you man.
You know,
like if I was 20 and someone said,
hey man,
you want to go to Disneyland and be like,
why?
What are we going to do?
We're going to ride a roller coaster and wait for an hour and a half little
funnel cake and suck each other off.
What's wrong with him and those,
um,
one of those fucking,
those the ones,
the brown sugar do I low,
nice Cherrelle got damn.
Those are hard to pass up the style,
dude.
You can't be on a diet and go to Disneyland.
It's hard.
They have a kitchen wrongs roasted almonds.
The churros do?
No,
not sure about like the,
if you had the stamp machines.
Yeah,
they have like the candy.
Uh,
almonds know what they want.
Have one thing that's guilt free though,
that big old Turkey leg that's smoked Turkey leg makes me feel sick when I see
just these enormous people just challen down and then the p meets all pink in
the middle for a reason.
Well it's smoked.
Is everyone out of shape?
Disneyland shape their ambulatory?
I'll dude.
Yeah.
There's more people that can't walk there just on scooters because they got so
big,
their body just stopped moving.
God.
Yeah.
It's a strange vibe though.
You can't be on a diet and go to an amusement park.
You've got to accept that you're gonna fuck off that day for sure.
That's a fuck off day.
That's like,
we're going to get some ice cream.
I'm a drink a regular soda.
Oh,
well do I tell you where else she can't be on a diet at Chicago.
I was there a few weeks ago.
Fuck it.
Go to Illuminati eight every pizza.
And I apologize to every crowd beforehand.
That is not a pizza.
That was a Goddamn casserole.
It is a straight,
it's the casserole.
It's a,
it's a pie.
It's a pie.
I do.
And I felt so sick after that,
but it was so nice going down.
I felt so sick.
That's a weird sacrifice.
Right?
You decide I'm going to be sick for a few hours for just a few seconds of mouth.
Pleasure.
Yeah.
Like again,
I apologize for the crowds.
I'm like,
shouldn't be doing this man.
This is this.
Take a fighter missing weight.
Like it's such an asshole move.
My face is all swollen from the sodium.
They'll go,
oh,
look at,
uh,
which one was that?
That was at the place where uh,
it's the famous place.
Um,
the grinder,
the grinder where it comes in a bowl and it's where a cracker is that is a gay,
that's an 80 case site.
Yeah.
But it's also a delicious pizza.
Chicago concept grinder often in grind of and grinder.
I wonder if they're bummed out that grinder as well.
All mother fucking,
and they thought you're going to get a deep dish and a blowjob dish.
Bitch,
but uh,
it's that same place where Al Capone and his men,
uh,
staked out before they did the Saint Valentine's Day massacre.
So it's like a storage place.
Yeah.
So it's old as fuck.
Two hour.
Wait.
Whoa.
You waited two hours for food?
Two hours away.
It's a two hour wait.
I put my name and strolled around a good move.
I know you gotta do what you gotta do that.
No,
there's no freebies there.
I don't give a fuck.
That's a lot of food,
man.
They don't fuck around.
People get cold.
That's the thing.
If you live in a place where people get cold like Boston or Chicago,
people get thick.
These take this.
Yeah.
They get,
it's tough to work out in the cold man.
No.
Well not just that.
It like,
it insulates you.
I that makes sense.
If you want to live in them,
don't want to be shredded.
Shredded near that water.
The wind comes off that lake.
Oh,
sense you've been Chicago in January.
Yes.
Woo.
Miserable as fuck.
Not My cup of tea.
It's great place to perform though.
Yeah.
Latinos are amazing.
Amazing.
There.
They're just fun.
They're fun people.
You know what they are.
They're a unique combination of like the Midwest and a giant city.
Same as Toronto.
Toronto is like that too of Toronto,
but it's the same kind of vibe.
It's a weird combination of like really nice,
almost small town people that live in a giant urban city and Toronto is a
melting pot.
It is just,
to me,
Toronto reminds me of New York,
not with the hustle and cleaner.
Yeah,
wait,
I loved her more polite people too and it's way nicer.
You get Indian people,
Pakistani,
black,
Asian,
white,
European mean you'd get everybody on the other end of that.
I was just in Seattle,
Washington and the crowd was all white,
all white.
That is the,
was the darkest dude in the,
in the building.
Damn.
In Portland,
they're white as fuck.
Even if you're black.
After a few generations you just turn white and you start talking.
Like if you're,
if you bring your family up there and you plan on sticking out of black
existence in Portland,
good luck.
Good luck.
If even if your kids only date other black kids test or like a hundred years,
everyone's going to be 101 there's no sun that sun for three months a year,
that there's a reason why people became white.
I mean everyone really comes from Africa.
It's one of the real reasons why racism is so stupid.
Every single fucking human being came from Africa,
just like every single fucking dog came from a wolf.
Every person started out as an African.
It's just as we moved to shittier and shittier places with less and less sun,
your body adapted and you basically,
white skin is like,
uh,
a big ole solar panel for vitamin B or Vitamin D rather.
I don't,
and obviously we don't,
I don't know anyone who is racist these days.
Still out there for sure.
But I don't,
I don't,
I don't want to have anyone that I even,
you know,
associates Niven but even like jokingly or like I don't like Asians and I don't
like,
I don't that is exotic.
No,
no,
not any that are doing well.
No,
it's a stupid mindset.
It's a stupid mindset.
It just really is.
It's dumb.
Just as,
I mean,
it's very old school.
While it's just,
it's,
it doesn't benefit you in any way.
It's super detrimental for your view of the world,
the way you interact with people.
It's just,
it's dumb.
I mean,
I know so many cool people of every single race.
Like what,
you know,
I mean,
why would you like judge and white people off of a few small portion sample size
of like mass shooters?
The dumb is shoot up the high schools.
Well,
this,
you know,
there's like blow back the other way,
right?
Like there's a lot of people think it's okay to be racist against white people
because so many white people have been racist in the past,
but that's just as foolish and just as short sighted.
It's different.
Yeah.
It's all stupid.
It's like today with all this meat to stuff,
um,
it seems like it's okay to be sexist against men because there are awful men out
there,
but there's also men.
They're nice and they're going to be nice to you.
There's also some awful women out there who do have other agendas when they come
out with these.
Me Too.
Claims there's a lot of that what you're seeing.
I mean,
we're seeing these cases now,
you know,
we're seeing these cases get exposed for what they are,
and it,
it,
the problem is that it casts doubt on legitimate cases.
What is going on with my throat?
Something about these goddamned caveman coffee's really early in the morning.
I'm good though.
Sometimes.
I know you think you thought,
did you think,
uh,
if you're in Lucy case shoes,
do you think he came back too soon?
I don't think it's that he came back too soon.
And what I honestly think is he should say something more than what he already
said,
not just fill up like it's all good.
And like,
right.
There's not just,
I mean,
he said he put out a release a statement.
These stories are true.
They happened a long time ago.
Right?
They happen like more than a decade ago.
I think he should.
And I think it might be even better to release a video rather than,
um,
than a written statement because a written statement,
the problem is like it's impersonal.
It's personal.
Fake.
Yeah.
Well it's not even,
not only that,
it's,
it's not as impactful.
I want us,
what is he going to say?
It's like I can't fix it.
Maybe if he donated a certain amount of money to certain causes or you know,
spent,
you know,
time in therapy or talked about it and it's,
and maybe expressed himself and said that.
What was,
you know,
what was going on through,
through,
through in his mind during that time when he did the thing and why it was wrong
and how he's changed his,
his way and how bad he feels about it.
How he's apologized and has daughters,
I think,
I think you could get all that done by just doing a video with his,
I think it would go so much further for him if he didn't have a big production,
nothing.
And he's a creative dude.
Obviously a great comedian.
If you just went off the top of his head straight into the camera and posted on
Instagram,
I was like,
hey man,
I've paid a price.
I've learned.
I have daughters is a horrible thing that I did.
I mean,
even stay away from,
I've paid a price because people don't really want to hear that shit.
Like what is the price?
But they don't think he has.
Well,
they're crazy,
but a lot of people,
millions of dollars,
they don't realize that.
They think,
oh,
he's fine.
He should get back down the road and touring is going to be a millionaire.
Well,
he slides a ton of shit,
ton of money off his shows.
Fx Deal.
More importantly,
his daughters have this image of him being,
this guy jerks off in front of women.
That's never going to go away.
No,
that's,
that's a pretty heavy stamp,
which is deserved.
Maybe not.
Maybe not forever,
but,
but it's,
it's a complicated issue.
You know,
it's complicated.
Like what was his psychology?
What was going on in his mind that that allowed him to do that apparently just
started going up again.
He just went up again Sunday night.
Yeah,
he just went,
he went up and I guess the,
the owner of the club was like,
dude,
I didn't know I was asleep and he went up.
You know,
it's the crowds discretion if they want to stay or leave.
But well the first time the,
the owner was upset in the second time they said something along the lines of if
anyone has an issue with someone who stops in Aka Louie.
I mean it's only Louie,
maybe Aziz I guess really well
some people got upset about it as east to still do,
to look at people just like targets.
They like targets that they like negativity,
they like negativity but they also like targets
when they find someone who a viable target,
someone who's done something they can criticize and then Kelly,
you,
what have you done?
Oh,
you're still alive.
You know,
there's people that just want to decide that someone's a horrible person and it,
and they don't have this really well thought out,
comprehensive view of the situation.
They just attack.
You know,
there's a lot of those people out there,
man,
and they think that they're justified,
particularly if that person is famous and they're not.
They think it's fair game.
Yup.
Published form.
And so people were definitely upset at Aziz,
but much,
much more upset about Louie.
Oh,
100% when you stop and think about what Louis actually did.
Creepy.
Yes.
Asked women if he could jerk off in front of them.
They said yes,
he did it.
If they said no,
he didn't.
I mean it's,
it's fucking,
look,
if you're working with a guy like that and he's like,
can I jerk off in front of me like Jesus Christ,
he imagined what the fuck it would be.
Shitty work environment for sure.
And he is not handsome Louie.
I love you.
Brutal to list.
You know what I'm saying?
He's harsh on the eyes.
Yeah.
Brad Pitt's asking to jack off in front of you.
Not that it's ever right,
but it do less on the,
it's in the feelings of Brad Pitt's.
Yank it in front of you.
I mean all of it.
All of it's no Bueno.
It's a whole mess.
I mean,
he obviously had some sort of a weird kink,
you know,
I wonder what that is.
Probably started in childhood,
maybe got caught and then got off on it and,
right,
right.
Or you just never got chicks and now he has this power because he's such a,
he didn't have the power when he started doing it though.
Man,
when he started doing it,
it wasn't a really famous,
he was respected,
but he was like,
no.
Which is some,
you know,
it's,
it's awful.
But it's,
it's just the thing that he stuck with now.
So he's got to figure out how to ingratiate himself.
He's got to figure out how to to re emerge and I think he can do it.
I think you can do it,
can do it.
Look,
he's not an awful person.
I just think he did some stupid things that were really gross and weird.
But if he just,
I mean he and he has owned up to it.
I think he just,
you know,
it makes some sort of a sincere apology and then does something like what could
you do to to,
I mean,
what do you help?
Female comics maybe do a duo has done that.
He's tried to help,
but a lot of people accused him of trying to help them to try to cover up his
tracks.
Well,
fuck man,
you got to yes.
To do something.
He gets to go back to work.
Yeah.
I mean it's been a year now,
right?
It's a year,
next month.
I think to expect him to just never work again seems ridiculous.
It's going to not forgive him.
There has to be a path to redemption for anyone who's done anything other than
actual rape or murder.
Right.
Like for Bill Cosby,
I'm very happy it's locked up.
I think what he did is awful.
Can you imagine being one of those girls that turn to him as a mentor and you
wake up and you,
you know,
you're,
you've been violated while you're out cold and you're dragged and you're
confused and bill Cosby did it to you and who the fuck is going to believe that
his image is?
That's the thing about Louis,
right?
Like Louise Image was like,
he's a pervert.
He's a Weirdo.
He's always talking about jerking off.
Like when you found out Louis CK ass got girls,
if he could jerk off in front of them and did it,
it's like not the most surprising.
No,
but with bill Cosby,
it's,
here's a guy who is,
and I'm not comparing the,
the acts at all,
but I'm just saying as far as like famous people who have done something that,
you know,
became a scandal,
would bill with bill Cosby,
he was this moral guy.
He was this like ethics guy and he wore a sweater or his dad.
He was America's Dad.
And to find out that that guy was drugging and raping women.
He's in fucking jail right now,
which is crazy.
Right?
He's going to die.
I give it over under a week.
Do you think the way it goes with those old dudes?
Really?
Yeah.
He's 81.
His eyes are show crazy.
You can't see,
I think the one's good,
but the last ones all over the goddamn place.
Which one is the one I thought the right one was wearing.
Ah,
it's,
I think it's this one,
but it is fucking look in the wrong.
What's going on in its own way?
Yeah.
That's what you get,
man.
It's yeah,
I'm going to die any day now.
I think,
um,
I a path to redemption or a path to retribution would be,
uh,
would be good.
A path to forgiveness.
That's,
that's the thing that's important for
all right.
All human beings who've made mistakes.
I think we cast people out if they've made
mistakes.
I agree.
I still think it's important to,
with all this stuff is like Louis C K got lumped in with the big dogs like bill
Cosby and Harvey Weinstein.
Then there's still only see k and man,
there was definitely different levels to this.
Yes.
These fucking crack question.
No question.
How about one that flies under the radar,
especially here in America.
And I was just reading about it,
how true it is.
Who knows is with a Ronaldo who you know,
and in soccer,
ash,
Ash,
your boy,
uh,
in,
in Edwards,
I mean there's,
there's a super superstar superstar.
It would be like a,
it'd basically be like Connor McGregor getting caught doing something for in our
world,
you know,
like it's a big deal.
This is a new one.
Yeah.
This,
this girl,
you know,
he said,
she said he kept telling him no,
and then he ain't,
he raped her and then a paid or a $375,000 to keep quiet and now she's coming
back out.
But who knows?
Human beings
capable of such amazing things and such fucking awful things might have to look
that up.
Jamie.
I might've been drained.
I think you're right about that.
My brother told me about it.
He's usually on it.
That's what I just read in the New York Post.
Yeah.
We should probably go back to fights,
right?
We're not aleks that booty.
Uh,
yeah,
we should go back to fight.
So,
I don't know.
Hmm.
Did outside of you about your,
your special being dropped today?
Nervous at all?
I was nervous before.
Yeah.
You're nervous about it?
Um,
yeah,
because still body of work you've been doing forever.
Cared about it.
I worked on it for two fucking years,
you know,
and you had it yourself for reviews are awesome.
Came out great.
I heard it's great.
I'm excited.
You know,
it's the best.
I think the best one I've ever done.
I really do.
I think the last one I think triggered was the best one.
And I think this one's better than that touch gill,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's how it should go.
Just keep working.
Keep,
okay.
Keep trying to refine it and keep an,
you know,
raise my standards.
I learned some stuff still after all these years doing stand up,
I'm still learning.
I learned some stuff in the editing process.
Really?
Yeah.
Well I learned some stuff just watching.
I think I re I listened to recordings all the time.
Um,
but I think I'm going to step my game up now.
And after talking to Bert Kreischer yesterday,
Burt,
he records audio and he also records video and I think I'm going to start
recording video of all my shows to now
it's top.
Oh yeah,
because when you're doing these giant theaters so there's not video cause like
how's that parlor?
Wherever I go they usually have video capability so I get all the video.
That's nice.
I always get the video.
Well the ice house can do that for me.
You know,
I can,
I could definitely get someone to do that for me at the store.
But I just think it's critical to see the way you move as well as here.
Like you got to analyze all that shit and try to figure out what you got to be
natural and in the moment.
But you also got to analyze the particulars and find out like what,
like owl,
I would watch like two or three different sets cause I feel in for shows and I
was like why?
Like why did I do that in the second show?
Like the way I did it there.
That's the way to do it.
Yeah.
But I did it differently in this other show.
I think the shitty parts,
watching yourself and listening to yourself,
it takes a real type of asshole to do that.
Right?
It's the word.
It tastes real type of asphalt.
A like it oh two and just like,
oh,
that was good.
Yeah.
You well that's pretty good.
Have you ever been over someone's house and they make you want,
they make you watch something that they did too.
Oh,
quarterback Vinny Testaverde.
He's a first round draft pick.
He played forever.
We went to his house and he made me watch the recap of his last football season.
Two our NFL films recap of the Baltimore Ravens and it was a nightmare.
I need you to sit there and recap.
It was so boring.
Shut the fuck promise.
I want to put a fucking bullet through my mind,
but how of the respect of any tests or Verdi and he'd beat my ass in basketball
before that.
I stayed there and watched it.
Ah,
who does that though?
I heard about a dude who,
um,
he had a party over his house and then when the people were over there,
he made them listen to him sing a song.
Is it Brian Cowen?
Nope.
Just kidding.
Some other guy.
I know who you're talking about it cause I think I was there,
played music and sang and was serious during the middle of the super ball.
Sir.
Put the Superbowl on pause and his band struck up a fucking song.
I looked around and went,
is everyone a terrorist here?
What was happening?
Why is the game paused?
I'm from Denver,
Colorado.
My put that Goddamn drum stick down.
I'm going to flip the flip the fuck.
That was the most Hollywood thing I've ever seen in my life.
I went,
well,
I feel sick and I'm going to leave now I feel very sick and then the middle of
the fucking game and my Broncos are playing too.
Oh Dude,
people are so strange.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
That's the most Hollywood thing I've ever seen in my life where I felt sick.
Yeah,
I've seen many of those.
I was over someone's house once and this guy ran outside to his car to get a
video to get us to watch a music video that he did was,
which was one of the worst songs I've ever heard in my life.
People like gray and it was a music video and as a music video that look there
is made for about $3 Oh God.
It was just like what the fuck?
And he's like singing all sincere in this music video and we're all sitting
around like we have to watch what torture.
It's just compressing my chest and a vice.
I'm like,
I can't breathe.
But you've never seen comics like played there hour special and they've had
people over.
I haven't seen that yet,
but I'm sure it's happening.
It's happening right now as we speak right now.
There's a like,
come on everybody,
sit down,
sit down.
It's time for my special,
come on everyone get around
fighting.
What did he laughing at?
Burke did that.
Her Chrysler did that.
No,
he did that with his family though.
They had like a screening.
No,
they have like a specifically was it friends and fit was his friends too.
Yeah.
But he,
no,
that's,
I hear it's a different thing.
Like he invited them to a screening of his special where that was the purpose.
It wasn't like he threw it on in the middle of a party.
Everybody should watch my special enjoying the music and I got pizza here.
Different.
Yeah,
it's different.
No,
it was a screening and his agents were there and his managers were there and
people that worked at is,
do you have a family come to your shooting?
Your specialist?
No,
no,
no.
Ma,
you know,
if someone from my family comes and watches me,
I mean they come to a show.
Yeah.
But then I'd come into the shooting of it and then no one ever asked them to
like if they want to.
But does your wife like to go or she's like,
she,
I have her come out like every six months or so.
See,
just to see like tell me,
tell me is it anything new?
Like what,
what's,
what's different because she's known you for so she would know.
It's like,
yeah,
someone's,
here's the thing,
if someone sees you every weekend,
and I have friends that take their girlfriends on the road with them and they
get so bored with their act cause they're watching a guy perform every night,
two nights in a row,
two shows in a night,
they fucking,
your act is nonsense to them.
Bottled Blah Blah,
blah.
You are my favorite people on planet Earth Mama come store all the time.
I've seen,
you know you're set when you're ready for this a bunch of times and when I was
leaving someone's like,
can I watch John?
Mike Do.
I've seen it man.
It's not disrespect.
Fuck.
I've seen it though.
I don't even watch like seen it 10 times.
I don't even watch my favorites.
Even Joey,
I'll sometimes leave the room if he's on stage.
Yeah,
you don't,
you,
you also don't want to get bored with someone's act.
You can't watch them over and over and over and over and over again.
But that's what happens with girlfriends.
Girlfriends would go on the road with guys there watching two sets a night.
What a terrible idea.
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Blah.
And then they just think you suck because they don't make them laugh anymore.
Hunched over it.
They're like,
really?
This is what you do.
You tell the same story every night,
shut up that you pretended to do story and then if you have a new opening act
like he's really funny.
Like he's funny.
What about me?
He's funny.
You know I've seen you too many times.
Like,
oh no.
Yeah,
my brother,
he's thinking I was great.
He's on the road to me every time and the other night,
here we go again cause I feel like I could do your ass mother fucker.
He seen it.
He probably didn't know it by heart.
We used to do that in Boston.
We had a thing called Joe Biden night at stitches and Joe Joe Biden,
who was the former vice president.
People don't remember this,
but in 1988 when he was running for president,
he got busted retelling some of Kennedy's old speeches.
Come on,
man.
This is an 88.
Yeah,
it was a big scandal.
So we uh,
and that kind of took them out of the running for being president for a long
time,
although they're talking about it again for 20,
20.
But he,
um,
so we would do Joe Biden night at the comedy store.
I would do your act.
Awesome.
That's hilarious.
People probably loved it.
Oh,
they loved it.
It was,
you know,
like an off night.
It was like a Monday you doing Joey d is a fuck.
Yeah.
Well that would be good because I can do an impression of Joel.
I know like a lot of it was just people just doing the material.
Christa,
Leah does Callan fucking great.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Comedy is a weird thing.
You know,
you do it too.
I mean,
that's one of the things about this special,
it's like I got too close to it.
You know,
like when you're editing things and you're practicing it and you're doing it
over and over again.
I know it's working.
I know I go to a cloud.
No,
it's going to work.
It's polished.
I practiced it.
I wrote it out,
I redid it.
I fucking edit it and change it,
twisted it,
and I know how to do it,
but I also don't want to hear it like I've not,
I've heard it too many times,
so you get too close to it.
So then when people are going to see it for the very first time,
you're like,
I don't know.
I hope they like it.
I just got to come too close to it.
Even after all these years.
Yes.
If you care,
you get nervous and it isn't it.
It's you're,
it's,
you're so close to this body of work.
Like you said,
this is your baby.
You know what I'm saying?
If someone's like,
dude,
that sucked.
You're like mother fucker.
There's definitely people that are going to think it sucks.
That's always going to happen.
But my thing is the majority of my fans who liked my comedy,
I want them to like her.
And so for me it's like I was confident.
I knew I did everything I could do.
I knew,
I know I'm a good comic and I know I've done everything I could do to make this
my best one.
So I knew I was confident.
I knew it was a good special,
and I thought it was my best special.
I'm very confident that it's my best special,
but it's still,
I'm too close to it,
so I don't know.
Anyway.
Yeah.
Well that's good transition this weekend.
This dude,
I'll tell you this,
I'm not being a hater.
I'm not being,
uh,
some sort of Debbie Downer.
I don't think it breaks 2 million paper view bys.
You might be right.
I'm not,
I'm not seeing it,
man.
Like when Connor fought Florida Floyd,
or when Connor,
uh,
Nate Diaz to,
I couldn't go anywhere without under Starbucks unit.
Anywhere shoe store where car dealer.
Everyone would,
dude,
Connor Floyd,
who you got man,
everybody in their mom.
Now,
very rare.
Maybe I'll one of my shows someone to bring it up.
But there's something that Connor didn't want to do for this fight and that's
massive promotion.
So does that mean it's not as big?
Like,
who's that fallen is at con or the you have Scott.
He doesn't want to do it.
Well,
the,
the UFC has a model,
right?
And it worked in the Josie Aldo fight.
That model is you just promote the holy
fuck out of a fight.
You travel the world,
you promote the shit out of it.
He screamed at each other at press conferences.
He do all that stuff for months and months and months.
And those things sell like crazy.
If it's Conor Mcgregor,
if it's Conor McGregor.
So who have they ever done it with besides Conor McGregor like that?
No one really sells like that.
They,
you know,
a little bit with Rhonda I guess,
but she didn't have the same kind of chops as Connor.
So Connor's the only one.
But you know,
I don't know.
Maybe it's cause he had a layoff mates after the Floyd thing.
I think it does.
Well,
I don't think it breaks,
uh,
converse.
Nate too.
Well,
I don't think your breaks 1.6 million.
What I think happened was Connor made a hundred fucking million dollars and he
was like,
yeah.
Um,
I'm just going to train.
You know,
I think,
I think there's that and that also goes,
I'm not,
that took so much energy to do all that and everyone knows me as that guy.
I have the toughest fight of my life coming up.
I'm taking every precaution necessary not to overtrain Yep.
Not to use all my energy.
This,
I'm in the fight of my life and I'm going to train like it.
I'm shutting down everything.
You can post the fucking me throwing the Dolly through the window 1000 times.
I'll do the press conference on Thursday.
Other than that,
man,
I have got to get ready for the fight of my life.
That's the way I'm looking at it.
I think you're right and I think this is the fight of his life.
I think stylistically it's a nightmare matchup.
I think it's a nightmare match up for both of them.
I think anyone who goes,
oh Connor,
you know,
he can't wrestle.
They can't do this.
He's just going to get taken down and pounded out your show off.
It's not even funny.
You don't know the game.
He absolutely is capable of stuffing a take down or two in the early going.
That's what's up because in the early going he's got that Stanger have a left
hand and put his movement.
His footwork meant his footwork and Khabib is going to know that coming in.
He's going to be a little hesitant.
He's not going to walk towards him like Edson Barboza did or he didn't.
The Edson Barboza fight,
you can't because Barboza is mostly kicks Barboza Tie stock kicks,
lot of Thai style cakes and Khabib just put a tremendous amount of pressure on
him and then got ahold of him.
But Connor is going to crack them with Hans and his footwork is way better.
Yes,
he's,
he's just way better at moving in and moving out.
I think when people go,
it's either Connor starches him and gets the Kale or it could be just takes him
down for five rounds and pounds him out.
I think a,
I think it's a,
it's a classic fight.
I think it's back and forth.
I think if they fucking dog fight,
I think it's a fight of our lives,
man.
I really do.
I think you're probably right.
I think you're getting a fucking great fight from two guys where there's more on
the line than just win or lose.
I think with Khabib and what he represents and talking to his team,
his team,
Captain Josh Thompson,
he goes,
could be,
he was going to retire after this.
Really?
He wants to beat Conor and retire.
You want to retire like the Floyd Mayweather of MMA 27 and know,
beat the beat the UFC,
you know,
poster boy and he's walked off in the sunset.
Unless they get,
I'm a super five just be or some,
he's done.
Really?
Wow.
That's shocking.
He's young.
Very shotgun.
He's,
but think how long he's been doing this since he's,
this whole has been fucking up and grizzly bears.
So he's like,
all right,
I'm over it.
This man,
and not to mention he lives with his family man.
He still lives his mom and dad,
his wife and his two kids.
Same House.
Wow.
That's kind of monster you're dealing with.
And then for Connor,
I think it's,
it's a legacy fight where you know,
he,
he's coming off the Floyd Mayweather kind of train.
There were,
you know,
it was a success.
Either way,
you look at it,
he made $100 million.
They compete against the best of all time and lasted more rounds.
Anyone thought and trained for a complete boxing match,
it was striking to me.
Better go in this fight.
But for him,
it's not about the money.
You see him,
the one interview he's done on Mac life,
they,
you can see it.
It's like,
it's a vintage Connor.
We go,
Oh shit,
we got one here,
man.
This isn't,
you know,
the Floyd Mayweather is more of a show.
Like we didn't think he was going to win that.
This one.
He looked at it.
Oh Shit.
That's vintage Connor.
This Mutha fuckers coming to fight and he might get taken down.
Yes.
I guarantee you he gets taken down.
I'm a fuck around and get back up and he's going to get up and he's a keep
getting up and used and keep coming and we've got a dock fight.
Man,
I think both guys can be fucked up after this fight.
And to me a classic,
he could be or as forward fucking just could be good starts in seven seconds.
People be playing this on
this,
on a loop.
Look Khabib's got to get through the fire.
You know,
he's got to get through the fire in the early going.
He's got to close that distance and he's got to do it with precision without
letting his nerves affect him.
Right?
I mean he's got all that shit talking con has done to him.
He seen him rattled at the press conference.
He's rattled when he started talking about his dad.
He's rattled and I think,
um,
we've,
we've also never seen Khabib fight with high stakes.
Like when he fought Alec went to that was in high stakes,
Aliza,
amazing fighter.
But that's not the same as fighting Conor McGregor when he's fighting a Edson
Barboza that's not in high stakes when you're fighting Conor Mcgregor,
Conor takes all the chips on that poker table,
puts it all in the mill goes,
I'm all in.
You have to be all in.
I do.
Well under these circumstances,
how do you respond?
Yeah.
So for,
we've never seen Khabib and everyone goes,
oh,
his cardio is great,
it is great.
But when the fucking Irish nation is rock in that fucking arena and there's all
this pressure,
his heart rate's gonna go up and he'd see like,
God,
I fucking hate this guy because he's never filed.
A guy who hates he hates con.
Yeah.
How is he going to be over zealous and open himself up?
Yep.
There has to be something there and we don't know exactly what all was an
assassin until that five complete it get the best of all time.
Yeah.
Still is.
But that,
that fight exposed how good Connor psychological game is because months and
months of being on tour with Conor,
those press conferences kind of stealing his belt and screaming at them and
getting in his face and then starches him with one punch.
Oh,
amazing.
But the what the,
what else is interesting is remember Connors and amazing counterpuncher well to
be an amazing counter puncher and he needed to guide a punch at you can be,
he's not going to punch at them,
right?
Unless it becomes an ego thing like you did with a owl or Edson Barboza was just
walked them down.
There's no respect.
He might throw some punches.
So it's me answering for Connor to find those angles when a guy's not playing
the game.
It's also,
it could be,
was that a history of struggling to make weight that he cannot struggle to make
weight for this fine.
He's gotta be on point.
He came in that press conference at one 74 they said this motherfucker started
camp at one 80 something like he's,
he's never been more serious where a fight,
which for people listening,
if you're saying like what buddy fights at one 55 he used to weigh 202 Hondo.
Yeah.
And then get down to one 55 and it was not good.
I mean the Michael Johnson fight,
he struggled.
He had like some real shutdown issues.
And then the Tony Ferguson fight,
they pulled him out of the fight.
He can't have any of that nonsense this weekend.
Oh No.
I don't think the,
the nonsense.
The only thing where like Jamie told me is going to the fight.
I would never go to this fight.
I think there's what?
I would not go this fight for this reason.
I'm a complete pussy.
I think something's going to happen.
The crowd between the Russians and the Irish,
I think that just the animosity between the two.
They hate each other so bad.
If this fight,
it happens for Conor.
You're going to have upset Russians,
but happens for Khabib.
Me,
I've upset fucking Irish.
I think it's good.
It's gotten bigger than just a UFC fight.
Really?
I do,
man.
You don't so hostile.
You think you wouldn't go to this fight because of the potential the violence
breaks out.
Correct.
I also don't like going to UFC fights.
I still don't like you're going to UFC fights.
Why don't you like it?
Because he used to fight.
It's just stressful for me.
I just,
yeah,
just super stressful.
If you feel like you're going to fight again when your dad get the nerves.
And I'm just like,
oh,
I go complete opposite of that now.
I try to get more relaxed,
you know,
when I'm doing standup,
I go,
I don't want to be in that scared mode anymore.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
My heart rate under sweating the whole time,
I'm just like around like sweating.
I looked like,
shit,
pull up that card.
Let me see the rest of the car,
dude.
If you're Tony Ferguson,
it's like,
oh yeah,
and Tony's fighting.
Right?
It's,
I know.
And he's funny pedis.
It's not an easy fight for comeback fight for total.
I mean,
I'm just amazed that he's able to fight again so quickly after knee surgery.
You don't,
what's interesting to me is I,
I asked Josh Thompson,
who knows could be you and I'll see you can talk to DC about it,
but they,
I go,
dude,
Tony's back.
Like if could be where to win,
huge fight Tony,
right.
And goes,
no interest.
Th that's fight does nothing to him mentally.
He just doesn't care about it.
Could be just doesn't care.
Yeah.
He's like,
not with Tony.
So he really just wants to fight Conor and then get out.
Get Out.
One step once DSP from,
from this,
from Josh Thompson's mouth from could be,
he wants to beat the UFC poster boy,
Dana's poster boy and walk the fuck out.
Unless they give him a super fight.
Who the fuck has ever been 26 and o as a champion.
I think that's the only one.
Yeah.
But 26 and,
oh,
for sure.
He's fucking,
who else?
Like champion undefeated.
Champion [inaudible] was on John Jones Fight Matt Hamill before he won the
title.
He thought met him on the ultimate fighter.
Roy Nelson bread.
No,
it wasn't the
ultimate fighter.
That was ultimate fighter finale because I fought Roy Nelson.
Jon Jones.
Right.
Not on the,
not on the ultimate photo.
You don't when they do the financial.
Yeah.
Um,
that's a bullshit laws though.
Oh my God.
You got to loss from whooping a dude's ass so bad.
You know what?
Um,
as far as unfair champions who,
I don't think there's one Hennen brow.
Oh,
he won,
but he lost his first fight.
Yeah.
Cannonborough losses the first time.
I know he was like,
he had like 30 wins in a row or some shit,
but had a weird loss back in Brazil.
Yeah,
he lost his first MMA fight rather Rhonda.
Okay.
Yeah.
Ron.
Rhonda was undefeated.
Undefeated.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Rhonda is only two losses where the two title fights between Holly and Amanda.
Let's see,
what do you got there,
Jamie?
What are you pulling up?
List of undefeated MMA champions.
Ben Asca and hanging around Ben aspirins for sure.
One of them put,
Ben asks her to me and I've had him on the podcast.
I've said this,
the guy,
he's my all Brian Arteaga but Brian or take isn't really a champion.
Well these aren't champions.
Are they?
These just you undefeated MMA fighters.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
These are champions.
Uh,
Ben's the one guy who I'd love to see coming out of retirement and fight could
be,
he's the one guy.
That's my biggest disappointment that that guy never fought in the UFC.
It's a fucking shame.
And,
but the thing is like,
Khabib wouldn't,
my,
nobody knows who he is outside of the hardcore guys.
Now why would you,
why would you fight them and maybe lose,
maybe get out wrestled.
Here's the only,
if you're going to say something about could be bs 27 Oh,
he really,
when you look at the body of work from Connor compared to Khabib assignment
close the,
the winds that Connor has are remarkable.
Yes.
You like the Max Holloway,
Chad Mendez,
Josie Aldo,
what he did to Eddie Alvarez.
I mean,
ridiculous,
ridiculous.
Yeah.
Nate Diaz.
When Nate Diaz loss,
like you just look at the,
the caliber of opponents that he's faced from a very young age.
It's a nightmare.
And they look at Khabib,
he's 27 no,
his biggest ones probably Barboza does when he was a little weathered,
but yeah,
no,
but Barboza and the as a perfect stylistic matchup for him.
So yeah,
we,
we don't know with Qb,
we know he's damn good,
but how good.
He's had one weird moment in his entire career.
The skin.
Michael Johnson,
when Michael Johnson cracked him,
wobbled him for a second and then took them down and smashed up Gleason,
uh,
t bow to bow fight.
Got a little dicey to did it.
Yeah.
Paul,
I don't remember that fight at all.
Um,
but,
but with,
with Michael Johnson,
it's funny to me because Michael Jansen landed that big overhand MPP.
People go,
oh,
could be has a weak chin.
I'm like,
well,
he's never been dropped.
He's never been,
he's never been signed.
The Johnson starched Dustin Poirier with one punch.
Don't forget about that.
Michael Johnson can fucking punch.
He's explosive is shit.
Yeah.
I mean he caught,
could be and could be.
Got What?
Rock for a second.
And then whether storm took him down,
smashed him.
It was a total dominant performance.
Yeah.
If you look at his performance like you look at is rather his resume,
Pat Healey was a tough fighter that,
that,
that showed,
able to heal.
He smashed able.
True Healer.
Remember Abel,
he took down more times than anyone inside that octagon 21 thing.
And you thought college wrestler and a strong guy to able strong as shit.
And that's Gleason.
Uhh,
t bow one is that 2012 that's [inaudible].
That's that juicy.
Yeah.
The real big fight was the Barboza fight and then ally Quinta was,
I mean as,
as as last minute as last minute gets.
And he still went five whole rounds with [inaudible],
which was interesting for a lot of people.
Like I talked to Eddie Alvarez after that fight and he was like very
interesting.
Very interesting.
Yeah.
I was like,
this is why you saw a lot of things in that fight,
honey.
He's like,
yeah,
he's like a,
you know,
once the,
once the fight got into the later rounds and he's still standing up with guys,
he let go.
Whoa.
All right.
It's so interesting to me because when you talked to anyone from AK,
obviously they're super pro could be,
but they're like,
dude,
this isn't even a fight like this.
What do you,
this is one of Khabib's easier fights.
He's definitely had way tougher match ups and like,
you're crazy man.
They're like,
you should see,
could be go against Ed Ruth,
who's an Olympic in Penn state wrestling.
He fucks him up.
He takes him down.
Like,
what?
But that's,
you know,
that's,
that's that wrestling,
you know,
that dance,
that rhythm.
Connor's not on that rhythm.
No.
You're talking about a different animal.
You talking about a guy who is one of the best fencers in the game,
meaning can like jump in with one shot and put you out and he can do it moving
back.
He could do it moving forward.
He can time you and he'll,
he'll be very common there.
You will get the very best.
Conor McGregor,
he's also no slouch on the ground.
People think he's just gonna get taken down and like get crucifix right away.
You're out your goddamn mind trains with Dylan.
Dan as he,
he's brought in these,
uh,
Dagestani wrestlers.
Like he's training with the elite of the elite.
He's,
he's,
you know,
it could be just going to do,
yeah,
it's way easier to train for Khabib than it is Connor.
The dark horse fight on the card is Derrick Lewis and Volkov.
It's a great fight.
Zander Volkov might be the best heavyweight on the planet.
What's he want his last six fight winning streak.
He's a guy who was flying under the radar.
It's giant to his last fight and knocked out for doing people forget it seemed
like six eight Isam.
Six eight yeah.
Six eight giant tall,
long dude who did real well in Beltour world champion belt and he has massive
experience and you see him in that fight with for doom.
He fucked her doom.
Oh no man,
he's the problem.
Interesting for doom.
Just released a statement saying that you saw to asked him to snitch.
I know what's going on with the snitch and stuff.
I don't know.
They offered him a Alene more lenient sentence.
If he was willing to snitch and he goes,
fuck you.
And John that too.
And I guess John was like,
cool.
I don't know.
I don't either,
but that's what they're saying.
I don't need a John snitched.
Did you hear Johnston?
That's,
that's,
that's what the statement says.
But John's manager says that he didn't stay.
What statement from who?
The statements from him.
His manager give skeptical hippo phase dude.
But no,
I'm not saying John.
Dude,
let's be very clear.
All I'm saying is he came out that statement and then Malka goes,
he didn't snitch and then everybody's like,
wait,
what the Wicki?
Novitsky was like,
no.
You said you're going give us some info to help us out down the road with other
people.
So you know I don't what?
Yeah,
you saw that to release an official statement went,
hold on,
wait a minute.
Because Malik came out and was like,
no,
we never agreed.
So we're going to snitch.
And then you saw it as like,
well,
well no,
remember really contracts you sign.
Here's this section of the contract.
He said they would help them out in the future with other people.
I mean,
but bring it up.
Jamie.
John John's world champion walking around wearing a wire.
Hey guys.
Hey,
can you just say working?
God,
everyone else?
Anyone else just exhausted today.
Cancer.
Just so you got your secret.
God,
anything bro,
why are you a full hoodie and sweatsuit in the solid?
I don't,
you know,
I'm going to go out on a limb here.
I don't think that Jon cheated.
I don't need a,
you don't think he cheated?
No.
I don't know.
It's very murky water.
I might be wrong.
I don't think he cheated.
I think he took something that was tainted.
I think that's why they're only giving them a year off and I think,
look,
I'd set it on the podcast and he's skeptical.
Hipaa eyes about how it's shortened sentence.
It's ready to go right around New York.
No.
Right around this ESPN deal.
Monkey says there was none,
but I keep saying that and everybody keeps running with it.
Substantial assistance doesn't necessarily mean it has to be on somebody else.
It could have been on himself.
What so go up to the part that you've sought us,
says that's what you sought a released.
That statement reached out and said,
there are two avenues above,
above antidote policy allow for reduction of sanctions.
One individual can get a sanctioned reduction if he or she provides information
that results in Usada or another antidoping agency bringing forward an
anti-doping policy violation against other athletes or support personnel and or
two or reduction can be given if the information results in a criminal or
disciplinary body,
bringing forward a criminal offense against individuals.
Importantly,
if the athlete or support personnel fails to continue to cooperate and provide
credible substantial assistance,
you saw we'll reinstate the original sanction,
that snitching where I come from,
but I don't know.
Now I don't think John snitched on anyone to get a shorter sentence.
We'll find out if Jackson guys are popping left and right all of a sudden.
But I don't think John did that.
I think that's just in there.
Maybe,
maybe or,
or if,
I don't know.
We do not know.
And I like to give John Jones the benefit of the doubt.
And I will say this,
if I'm like UFC fighter,
I am hiring mouthy to be my goddamn manager.
Cause what he's done with John,
what he did with,
um,
frickin all his guys.
You what he did with,
uh,
your boy Yoel Romero,
he goes to bat for them.
No one else is fucking with the golden snitch like Malika does.
And everyone else kind of just goes,
ah,
fuck.
We got busted man,
not Maliki,
man.
That dude's going to the end of the earth.
The fight for your freedom.
Yeah,
he,
and it seems like know him that well,
I don't know him as a person,
you know,
managers or managers,
but I'm saying if I'm the UFC,
because they can't negotiate your sponsorship,
it's Reebok.
So what can they really do your contract and now you've got to deal with you
Sato who is a huge deal.
Mackey's this fucking dog right now that you want in your back pocket.
And it's interesting that you saw that as just released.
They released a statement that they're changing their policies.
So say if you piss hot,
they don't.
And what's really interesting is Sean O'malley and right afterwards said,
Yo,
I pissed hot.
He said,
they don't want to announce people pissed how?
He goes,
I pissed hot.
And he goes,
let me tell you something.
Um,
they're going to check my supplements and,
uh,
we,
we think we've got it nailed.
We think we know what it is,
but in the meantime,
this is why I was removed from his fight this weekend.
So they're not going to announce it.
Just going to pull you from the card.
They're just going to pull you from the card.
That ain't right.
And they don't announce it.
That didn't right.
And then they go through the entire steps.
And then if you're exonerated,
you were never accused in the first place.
See,
the problem is,
is with Sean O'malley,
with whoever you are,
Travis Browne,
whoever name any fighter you want,
if you've ever been,
even if it's even been hinted,
if you've ever had an issue,
um,
and you get that label,
nothing like people just go,
he's on steroids.
They don't show big announcement going,
sorry,
we didn't find anything my bat.
Hey,
Josh Barnett.
So I've been out for 22 months,
my bat.
Right?
What the fuck man?
Right.
Gimme some sort of compensation.
That's true.
Also you.
So it took you how long to figure this out.
I can't work during that time period.
And because of you,
I can't work and you made the mistake.
How are we going to make this?
Right?
Oh I bet you can go fight now.
That's insane.
Especially for Josh.
She's like 37 he's not young.
Or how about friends?
Zach's the older than 37 Josh might be 40 yeah,
he's not.
He's long in the tooth.
He's been doing it for a hot minute.
Yeah,
I mean he was.
But think if you're John Jones though,
dude,
let's say he lets say you're right and he didn't do anything.
Nothing on purpose and it was some bullshit supplement and he's been dragged
through the mud up.
Rightfully so after hitting a woman pregnant,
all that.
But with this,
that's a different thing.
That's a different thing with this,
you're like,
what the fuck man,
I could've fought Brock Lesnar.
I come a double,
I can live in dcs life but because of this I've been out,
I've been,
my name has been tarnished forever.
Yeah,
but there was something in his urine.
There was a substance and that substance is a performance enhancing substance.
The real question is did it come?
Like there's a lot of people that got it from supplements.
I mean this is happening all throughout sports,
but then there's people that say no,
they're saying that it happened from supplements,
but really that's just an
excuse for p for them getting pop.
That's what most people,
yeah,
the majority side with that.
The problem in John's situation is that he tested negative and then he tested
positive and he tested negative in a very short period of time,
which means that the amount that was in his system is a trace amount,
which is not anything that you could take that would impart performance
enhancing benefits.
They said it like having a drop of steroids and a huge vat of water.
Right.
It's like a benefit.
It's not about some people and not me,
man,
I'm,
I'm with you.
I maybe did take something that he wasn't supposed to,
but I don't think it helped his performance.
But um,
some people say,
oh well that he was micro dosing so it didn't give out of a system in time.
That's why such small trace amounts,
but at the time if there would a test and been a higher potency maybe.
I don't think you can microdosed this shit though.
I have no idea Joe.
I don't know but,
but listen,
they said he didn't do it.
Here's the shitty thing though.
Now dcs upset cause they're like k DC.
We're going to strip you of one of your belts and John's going to fight for it,
but they haven't worked that out yet.
Maybe you want to try the Gustafson Jon Jones situation is still hasn't been
resolved yet.
Dang.
We're gonna find out this weekend.
Do you think we see how the card,
yeah,
I think this weekend they'll have to announce they have to announce soft fucking
month away man.
I mean what else do you do that knee that you know,
this is a great card.
I'll see the main minutes.
Ridiculous.
But that mask where garnering cards a better fight.
Better,
better overall fight.
No,
I think it is to,
this is look the,
the big fights on this card or Norma Madoff and a Ferguson versus a pedes nurse
number coming off Parsons.
Connor's a fight for the ages.
I mean,
that's absolutely one of the biggest fights in the history of the sport.
That's a giant fucking fight.
I mean undefeated champion who just smashes in malls,
people against one of the most enigmatic,
charismatic fucking superstars a sports ever known and he's coming off of a long
two year absence from MMA where he fought the biggest boxer on the planet earth,
arguably the best boxer ever,
and went 10 rounds with them and then he's going from that to finding neuropsych
and Madoff again for the title is a giant fight.
Huge.
Right.
The biggest fight in UFC history for sure,
Connor is changed the sport.
I mean,
he really has forever.
He's a different thing.
He's different than all,
all the rest of the fighters.
He's just different.
He's so much more of a superstar.
Yeah.
He's more literally like it.
He's more of a,
he's the biggest celebrity with the best talents they've ever had and not doing
other things too.
He's like,
Fuck your movie.
So He's,
he's at some crazy,
I know firsthand.
He said some crazy offers from Ricky didn't take it that and were like,
no,
he didn't want to do it.
He says he wants to be loyal to the game.
He said there's plenty of time for that bullshit when I'm done fighting.
Brilliant.
Yeah,
I mean that's the way to do it.
I mean,
I think that is one of the things that did Rhonda in said she was doing
everything.
I mean they had her doing movies,
they had her doing TV,
shad dinner and but also is the skillset with Connor
to little different,
he has this skill set.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
It's a more comprehensive camp too.
I mean there was a Achilles heel with Rhonda was the camp.
I mean you look,
if you're fighting someone like Amanda Nunez,
you better be fully prepared.
It's just different to,
you know,
with,
with the female division II,
it's still growing.
So you know,
she,
what she was in her time period was one of the best of all time is the pioneer
of the sport.
But you know,
there's so,
so much in their infancy of starting with mixed martial arts,
they're adapting fast.
So Rhonda didn't get better when everyone else got a lot better that they caught
up to her.
She didn't have the skill sets.
And I think there was,
I think you're right.
I think it hurt her game didn't advance.
But I think there's also,
I mean just,
but she was so fucking good compared to them in the beginning.
She was just so good.
And then she was doing everything she was doing.
TV shows,
movies,
it's just the wrong people around from her management and her agent Brad,
like the whole thing was a nightmare.
The whole thing's a nightmare.
So she's doing all that stuff.
Totally worked out all these distractions and worked out financially up to a
point.
Well when I say to me were big ones,
big ones.
I mean it worked out in the sense where,
you know,
she don't stop now.
She looks happy.
She's in the WWE.
She's a huge star over there.
She's actually really good at it.
She's killing it over there for sure in the WWE.
Apparently she's like a natural at it.
Right.
So she's the champ over there and not getting him the face.
So just that brain down.
It's,
yeah.
Well,
well he's still get brain damage.
Yeah.
So I guess it kind of worked out.
But I mean when you,
when you're talking about Khabib and Connor,
you're talking about this too,
most skillful lightweights of all time about one guy is,
uh,
the best grappler we've ever seen in the UFC and could beam.
The other is the best striker we've ever seen in the UFC.
One of them for sure.
I think he's the best,
far as timing as far as putting all together his movement.
We've never seen anything like it.
Not even,
I think what he does is complete different with Wonderboy does,
oh,
we seen a one.
I can go watch that.
I'm not taking any credit away from one to,
but I'm saying from Wonderboy coming over with his kickboxing background into
UFC that we've seen some of that wonderful.
It's just the best thing is you've never seen Conor fight a guy like Wonderboy,
whereas you've seen Wonderboy fight Darren till you've seen Wonderboy fight
someone who's that kind of a striker and never seen Conor fight someone who is
as dangerous standing up as he is.
Jose Aldo.
Yeah,
but it was a different weight class really.
He was at the new somebody's finger,
but at the time,
right.
Like remember Joseph autos,
they fucking assassin.
Yeah.
We like what he did to Joe's eight for whatever reason,
puts this shade over.
Josie.
Josie was so good,
man.
It's true.
As a killer.
Striking was amazing.
Everyone was hanging off his Brazilian nuts and they get starts in 13 seconds
where like,
he's,
all right.
Well then the question is like,
did Connor catch him when he had already taken in a lot of damage?
Like after the second Chad Mendez fight?
People started to question because then second fight,
you know,
that was great.
Yeah,
no,
it's good point.
But then,
and then he fights a young Max Holloway,
you know they're both young.
That's not an easy fight.
Beats Max Holloway and has a torn fucking ACL or MCL in his knee.
Does that he fights Dustin poray you like,
you look at the guy like Max Holloway champion portray.
He's fighting fucking Nate Diaz now.
He could easily be the one 55 champion.
Eddie Alvarez champion.
Chad Mendez champion.
What do you know about,
but you know Chad is super last minute notice.
No Cardio.
Didn't have a camp but I'll just a window when brother.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
But there's a caveat next door.
Sure.
But still,
what are you hearing about Max Holloway?
Like how's he doing?
Fighting the,
they just got announced in Toronto.
Yeah,
he's getting to go bad weight cut from what I hear.
Real bad way cut.
Yup.
So how the fuck is he going to wait and make that way again?
Probably go,
what did we do last camp and Redo everything.
I mean he's so big,
dude.
He's so big or take is big too though,
man.
He figured this out but he hasn't been doing it as long.
Like the the,
I think the thing about the weight cutting is,
and this is like one of the things that I've been learning,
talking to nutritionists and guys who,
who diet and guys who get ready for bodybuilding competitions,
like talking to Eileen Norton last week,
who is a,
he's a scientist,
like a legit phd as well as a guy who's competed in bodybuilding.
He's like,
she's,
your body does not want to do that and your body tries to protect you from doing
it and the more times you do it that more and more difficult.
It is free to do weight cutting is the number one primary problem with MMA
hundred percent you got to listen to Karma Carter's interview that did with Mac
life.
You talked about weight cutting.
What did he say it just a I d I missed that part,
but he,
he talks about it how you know,
the,
the weight cutting was an issue and how dangerous it is and it's not good.
It's fuck yeah,
he,
he touches on that.
Yeah.
Dustin poray talked about that too and he said that he thinks everybody should
go up one way class,
but then you know what is happening with this 165 pound title because they were
going to have Nate Diaz fight.
Dustin.
Both those guys came out and said they're going to be fighting for the title.
They came up with that game plan,
which I love.
They tried forcing the UFC his hand today.
Yeah,
it was their idea,
which is hardly that.
C'Mon.
I mean that's the plan and then the UFC is like,
no,
they're not.
Like Dana goes,
I don't know why they keep saying this stuff.
Nate's,
they sign a contract.
They're finding at 55 65 no,
they're not fine.
Fine at 65 really know that.
That that,
that they're not fun.
It made the Nate Diaz and does support.
I thought it'd be great to find at 65 for a title.
Really?
That's not the UFC his idea.
I made that up so the UFC had to repost like notes 55 so it was like Destinee,
Hey,
what's up?
What's up dude?
Maida Vale failure.
I know.
Let's do this,
man.
Let's say we're going to fight this grade five.
All right,
fuck it.
You know I'm a fuck you.
I'll fuck you up.
Yeah,
it's,
I thought it was buying and then they tried forcing EFCs hand and then Dana to
come out and they know that.
So people,
and then when they told him it's not happening,
you know,
there's no belt.
There's no six five pound belt.
Nate was like,
oh fuck it.
I'm out.
Well it's,
what is
this is nick saying,
I'm happy to announce on bringing a neon blue,
what does that 165 pound belt super fighter division.
What does that mean?
Okay.
He is just this dim like trolling the UFC,
which is hilarious.
And then,
uh,
Dustin goes,
it's been a long journey,
but here we are a New York City first ever once he brought down title UFC one
65,
like how he hashtag Thug Jitsu shout out to Eve Edwards.
Uh,
it's hilarious.
But then you look at it and uh,
Dana White did absolutely no truth to it.
No,
it just doesn't make any sense.
But the,
here's the thing,
if there was true to it,
maybe you could sell that title better,
that that card better.
If that's the title five,
but you don't have a clue what you should do.
They fucking teen it up for you.
What are you waiting for?
But have that as well as the main event.
Do all right.
Get another main event.
Why not go?
All right.
Fuck my ego.
Let's do it.
Nate.
Dustin wants 65 world title,
New Division.
Everyone's all crunk for it.
If John Jones or whoever we're trying to get out so it works great.
That's going to hype this thing.
You'd be more but a month out.
Do that.
I would love dus important and Nate Diaz can headline this fucking mask
regarding card.
Yeah.
It's insane.
Not to announce someone,
but I think they want something bigger.
I think they want Jon Jones,
but ah,
but at one 65 title,
why not just,
why not just the appetizer?
That's it.
Deep heavy appetizers to Celtic.
Here's the craziest of crazy questions.
Please.
DC is supposed to be fighting Brock motherfucking last dorm right out for the
heavyweight title.
But that's next year.
John Jones versus DC for the heavyweight title in Madison Square Garden.
Yeah,
it's not happening,
but hey,
why not?
Because [inaudible] said he can't.
They want him to fight camp.
What happened?
Because he wants to find that light heavyweight and uh,
John and I think Dana One fight heavyweight,
but he wants to do it at light heavyweight.
He doesn't want to do it.
A heavyweight,
he doesn't want to fight John at at heavyweight light heavyweight.
That's always been saying,
oh,
somebody needs to pull him aside.
Give him a fat bucket of Popeye's fried chicken because that's his favorite.
Bye Bye.
Fat Buck.
You mean fat bucket of cash?
So I was going to say next.
Okay.
I was say to say a briefcase slide back up frank trucks on other briefcases that
has those click click things on it.
You lift it up.
Oh,
if I'm DC,
I'm not doing that.
I'm going hold up.
I'm going to fight Brock in January,
February.
I'm going to get paid.
I'm gonna beat the shit out of Brock,
right?
That's a big payday for me.
And then have John Fight cane have John fight steep at heavyweight.
Let's see how he looks.
If he looks human,
I'll fight that full.
But if he looks like Uber Remat heavyweight,
I'll see you on the other side and I'm fucking retiring.
That is a fight,
right?
Steve Bay versus John Jones at heavyweight and Madison Square Garden.
That would be a giant fight.
Huge fight.
That's a giant headliner.
That's a headline
twice,
I guess my debit card.
Now here's one for you though.
Why not like a see Connor versed,
uh,
could be the same biggest fight of all time.
UFC history,
paper use.
I don't think so.
But let's say DC to beat Brock.
John Beats Steep Bay.
John Deasy the trilogy at heavyweight for the world title.
You don't think that's bigger than this fight this weekend?
To me it's bigger.
No,
it's not bigger because Conor McGregor is a bigger,
what does this,
we might see Daniel Cormier,
Jon Jones trilogy had heavyweight.
Ah Ha.
See what I'm saying?
See what I'm saying on a force.
My boy,
D C and shit.
He doesn't want to do bro.
Uh,
stay strong DC.
None.
No,
no,
no.
Take the fight.
No.
Take that file.
Fight Brock.
Listen,
John's been off a long time.
Do you remember when he came back ends omen St Pru wasn't the best.
That's true.
This might be the time.
What a great story for DC.
Free to if you were beat John and then riding off into the sunset,
managing that
and then rides off into the sunset to play devil's advocate.
What if he gets head kicked again?
Heavyweight,
who's his boss felt everyone was like,
well,
there you go.
Well look,
John Is,
if not the best ever,
he's one of the best at,
I think he's the best ever with mighty mouse having lost its,
it's a real good argument I think in terms of like the overall ability to get
things done.
You got to look at what he's done.
He's never lost the only loss to Matt Hamill and that was a bullshit law.
We get the guys he's fought to,
fought my way,
beat them.
Two killers.
Remember when he choked Leo down and just dropped him.
This just fell in a clump and then the,
then the,
what he did to fucking [inaudible] bell four submitted.
Peter was like,
you're a black belt.
Vick.
Conor McGregor.
Not Keen on facing GSP next,
but interested in Anderson Silva.
Get that shit out of my face.
Kind of what,
why would he not be interested in facing GSP?
But he's interested in facing Anderson and [inaudible] of one 85 pounder.
We'll see what happens next.
But I don't think GSP is next.
He doesn't have anything for me personally.
I'm not going to shut the door on that down the line.
You know what would be another great one?
Anderson Silva.
I think he thinks Anderson is slow.
The shitty down.
George has not slowed down yet.
Uh,
Georgia 55 verse Connor's amazing fight.
Well,
it's 70.
It's an amazing fight.
Did not find it.
70 no.
Nope.
No Way.
Nope,
not happening.
Wait,
what makes you say that?
What makes you say that you've seen a Georgia?
He looks pretty svelte.
Well,
I saw one picture of him when he was in the sauna.
When people say he's making a test cut to 55 astro boy for us.
What can ask George?
That's George.
He's calm up right now.
Call him up.
That's I phone.
You think he's gonna give us a real answer on it?
Anybody during either.
Sometimes Brian Does the nightmare.
It's probably rude,
right?
Have,
they're like what?
You're on the air.
Hey,
it's Rogan and shop.
Is there any way you're going to fight?
And they're like,
dude,
come on.
Dad is like,
he's leaning in and that that image of him at one 70 is in the middle of a
fight.
So he's all pumped up with muscle is his muscles are inflated,
you know,
hey,
might actually be trying to make 55 he does look very slim there.
This is what I've heard through the grapevine.
GSP wants to,
wants to fight and the fight he wants up to is that 55 but it's only a Connor
wins.
Really.
He doesn't think beating could be,
would be like a legacy fight for,
well,
I'll tell you what,
in terms of paper view,
that would be a giant fight.
Conor GSP,
especially after GSP.
Boy beat beat.
Bisbing got 800,000 pay per view buys after two how many years out of the game
for four years out of the year layoff,
four year layoff comes back beat.
And I'll tell you what,
man,
when he did my podcast,
he's super lucid.
He's there 100% yeah,
like all that wrestling him.
Good,
brilliant.
Got arrested him.
Good smart,
smart guy.
That's a fine.
A giant fight.
That's a giant fight.
And he probably be vulnerable at 55 yeah,
it's a good life.
It's good.
Fight for counter.
Good fight for Georgia faster.
I mean,
would it be fair he wouldn't,
wouldn't necessarily be faster at 55 I don't think so.
I think you'd be so diminished.
Yeah.
I think it'd be solid offices,
techniques still there.
But I think 70 that's George all day 85 not so much.
That boy looked thick.
Yeah.
But he said he had a real hard time keeping that weight on it.
Fucked up his intestines.
Yeah,
whatever it was.
His digestive systems thick.
So he's eating all day trying to keep the mass on.
Yeah,
that's a rough one.
he's got some sort of a stomach issue now.
Collitus yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
From and he said he got it from just eating like a fucking pig while he's
training.
Like he was always like almost throwing up Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Not Good.
Um,
what else is on this card this weekend?
Pull it.
Pull.
Other than that man,
what do we got?
Michelle Waterson.
Felice.
Eric.
That's good to fucking fight yet.
Little Pettis fight and juicy.
Yay for Megan.
Yeah.
Tick in the box and world.
You've got Deontay wilder,
Tyson fury fight men doing the press conference Wednesday.
I know that's an interesting fight to get fired with Teddy Atlas said about
Deontay wilder.
Just how hard he can hit.
He called him Thor is,
he's got that hammer.
How great's Teddy Atlas.
It's great.
That was a fun interview yet.
I didn't get to the end,
but he,
he mentioned something of it where he was saying how he thinks an issue and I
never really thought about until you brought up,
I've never thought about it.
How in bought,
when [inaudible] came a little corrupt and got a little weird for him is when
the fighters started have their own promotions in,
in with the boxing world.
Right?
Like the promoters and the fives working together.
And now we see,
we're starting to see this now with the UFC.
We're going down the same road with condom,
with McGregor promotions in the UFC.
Now they're in cahoots.
Right.
But he's also talking about how the promoters would take out the judges to
dinner,
you know,
and he's like that.
That's a total conflict of interest was me.
Even if you're not paying them,
they're,
they're eating at the nicest places,
drinking the nicest wine.
So sketchy man.
Yeah.
So sketchy.
It's legal in some sort of strange loop.
Holy Way.
It's very strange.
Yeah.
What else is coming up down the future?
What else is going on?
Like what's a,
another big fight?
December,
the December card,
you got Cyborg Nunez happening now,
that December card in Toronto,
no December card.
Toronto's Briner Taiko Holloway,
right.
There's,
and so there's another December car,
New Year's card,
you know when they do it right.
Oh,
so there's two paper views.
This is like pretty sure the place that Valentina Shevchenko versus CJR.
You banks what bumped it for the vacant flyweight title?
What headline?
UFC Two 30 I thought,
but I thought Yolanda.
Yeah.
Yup.
Okay.
Is this just coming out today?
Just how I was.
I was about to show you a tweet that said that they were talking about moving it
up and it was in flux and then when I went to look for it,
oh wait,
that's going to headline math square garden.
What?
I've lost all energy in my body.
Oh yeah,
because that gets my Dick Carter.
Then Dustin poray was Nate Diaz for 145 pound title.
No,
no offense,
but I don't even know who says Yara Eubanks is and I'm the commentator for the
UFC.
I've never heard of her.
I am not being a dick either.
I'm just saying as far as headline,
Mass Square Garden,
you got some nerve,
whoever put this together.
Let's see a video on this young lady.
I'm sure she's an absolute monster and good for her.
She is it.
Congrats.
Looks scary.
How many fights did she have?
She's in the UFC.
She's one file up,
one fight in the UFC and she was born too foreign too.
Okay,
and what happened with you,
Ana?
She must got injured or some shit you on.
This is the previous tweet was this?
Well,
this is Brett Okamoto.
He's a reliable source.
Remember Espn?
The UFC now supposed to face Yolanda,
but that may change.
Two of the switch happens.
Okay.
Per sources they've discussed moving volunteer shift Chanko.
Is this the previous previous one and then he made another one saying that it's
locked down?
Correct.
Wow.
Okay.
Yeah.
Britney spears.
The,
who's that dude?
What's that guy's name?
Christopher [inaudible] Tano.
Chris underscore kiss Dano.
That's hilarious.
He put that Brittany Spears of
that is these poor girls.
That sucks for them,
but the magnitude of maths square garden,
you're thinking it's going to be,
so I was thinking Joan's fucking Cain Velasquez.
I'm Steve Bay Jones,
DC.
Less something that would blow my hair back.
Then I can hold up Valentine against the girl was foreign to with one fight in
the UFC for the flyway title is and then we'll go Montana.
They stripped her because she didn't make weight for one fight.
But yeah.
Those are your friends Joe.
Hey,
just kidding.
Listen man.
I don't want to be a promoter.
Fuck that.
You just keep doing it then.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck that job.
Fuck.
You'll be working.
I was going to say we could have done a companion just fricking.
Yeah,
Ham.
I know.
We could damn it.
When are we going to do,
when is everyone together?
When are you not working?
I don't know.
What am I under the hour again?
Well,
I'm a,
I'm chilling out for a while now that uh,
I got that show that I did in Toronto on Saturday night.
It was my last big show for a long time and you to chill quite a while because
you got to get another hour.
Yeah,
I'm at like 25 minutes,
24 minutes.
You still going to be doing sets or it might be nice taking a little break,
taking this week off.
Just the week of,
yeah,
just relaxing.
Then go into the UFC this weekend.
Yeah,
hanging out with the family.
Yeah.
I'm just looking forward to just,
I did it.
It's out now.
I'm a chill and then I need to,
we need to wait till October is over so I could do some mushrooms and he gets,
no,
my Dario.
Hey,
you're in sober.
Sober,
sober October.
Are you going to do sober October?
I don't drink or smoke.
Really.
I have nothing to be sober to say.
You're doing it.
I mean she,
I mean,
yeah,
I do it year round,
but sure.
I want to get involved in the fitness challenge.
Yeah,
that's easy.
Let's do that.
I'll get you in that.
I got an extra one of these things.
Really?
All right,
let's do it.
Okay.
I just work out with you guys.
You're in for,
I mean a man.
What is it?
What do I get to wear this thing right here?
The head.
Can I turn into a headband?
No.
You put it around your waist.
Oh,
sick chests and then I download the APP.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm in one of those.
I ordered an extra one.
Fuck yeah.
Thanks dude.
Right?
I'm in,
Dude.
Yeah.
It's not much for me though,
cause I don't really drink or smoke or anything like Stan hopes a big one.
Yeah.
He's got to go to a doctor.
Standing up is getting measured.
He's getting his blood work done and the doctor is going to go,
you should be dead.
I met him for the first time at the comedy store is Super Nice Guy.
Oh,
he's the best.
Unless you heard about him forever.
Yeah.
Really Nice Guy.
He's a sweetheart.
I just think guys going to be mean to me for what reason?
Smiling.
Complex,
but he's super nice.
He's going to be mean to you.
Yeah.
Yeah,
because a few of them have been,
yeah,
somehow.
Yeah.
Fuck this guy.
People do they think you're infringing on their turf?
You know,
I get it.
It's stupid.
I 100% comedy is everybody's turf.
If you can do it,
you can do it.
As long as you don't steal,
it's everybody's turf.
As long as the crowds laughing,
you don't steal the crowds in the laughter,
then yeah,
I don't belong to be there but don't steal and you know,
come up with your own shit and be nice to people and everyone should let you in.
We're all freaks and miss fits the idea that one type of freaking misfit is okay
but another type isn't.
Yeah.
You know,
I had to deal with that.
My,
especially early on.
You self conscious early on because you're a bigger dude and you have tattoos
where you self conscious of it.
Yeah.
That's why to this day I always go on stage with long sleeve shirts.
I people say,
oh,
like one of the things that people said about,
um,
strange times,
like,
why don't you wear fucking shirts that fit you?
Because I don't feel good and sure it's a fit.
Me.
I mean,
I,
I don't mind wearing a shirt that fits me to the movies or to a restaurant or
something like that.
Stage yourself loose things that don't show muscle.
They don't show any.
I don't want anybody looking at my body.
Yeah,
I hear Ya.
mainly.
Yeah.
Like you gotta you couldn't go onstage with a fucking tank top on.
People are like fuck this guy.
Right.
And he has skinny jeans on.
Theo goes on stage with a tank top.
I know.
It's all good.
You know what I mean?
You can create a problem.
Don't tell Brian he can prime to get upset.
So no cock guys just think of ripped.
Nah,
come on.
Do a lot of body weight work.
You know what I found a legit massage lady.
All my God,
this lady tortured me the other day.
Do I know her?
No.
She's um,
she is a trigger point specialist and she gets,
she's a strong lady and she gets that fucking elbow in your bag.
Big Girl.
Ooh.
Yeah.
She's a big hand.
She's big late.
That's how you know she's fucking strong card.
Yeah,
she broke me.
That distracts me.
But it's good for you to my whole back to this day,
still sore was two days ago.
I got the massage and the areas where she broke down our soar,
like she fucked me up,
but she paid my ass.
That was in an hour long though.
She did 90 minutes.
She dripping wet with sweat,
wet like hey.
It's like pros and cons,
right?
It's like you either get the bigger,
the sweats and takes up all the oxygen in the room or you get the soft Asian
girl.
It's not a good massage.
No,
I don't want that.
I want to get hurt.
Yeah,
me too,
because she loosened up a lot of shit that was bothering the fuck out of me.
I realized the importance of that and I haven't been doing it.
I'll tell you what,
when I do yoga regularly,
I don't need as much massage,
but I think even then you need it.
You needed everything to be king,
all the kinks to be worked out broken down and yeah,
I love massages,
man.
You know,
the Russian Olympic team,
I was reading something about a Russian athletes.
They would get massages every day on tons of steroids,
but yeah,
sure.
It makes sense.
Did you ever have that guy,
Bryan Fogel on your podcast?
Bryan Fogel.
He's the guy that directed ICARUS.
No,
I didn't it did you see Hickory?
I saw liquors a ridiculous should have him on.
He's amazing.
Here's my thing,
Joe,
like when you had teddy atlas on for for him to come on in three hours,
you have that uh,
Bryan Fogel or whoever,
when they do three hours on this,
there's not much more I can cover.
Sure.
I'll throw in some dick jokes or something and I got talking about dicks and
fashion,
but once they go here,
like I don't want to say that.
No,
no.
Their conversations,
the conversation about it as a kind of say shape for three hours.
Yeah,
but believe me,
you're going to cover it in a different way.
It's always how it is.
You're going to have your own take on things,
especially as a guy who's actually fought professionally but actually played
football.
My only thing is
as a ma,
it's my own things.
Like if I hear it on your show for three hours,
I don't want to go over it on my show.
I'm like,
I know this guy.
It's not a mystery anymore.
I see what you're saying.
But I don't think,
I don't think that way.
You're like,
I,
when I heard Jocko on Tim Ferriss,
I didn't say,
oh,
I don't want to have that guy on because Tim Ferriss covered it thoroughly,
which he did a different,
yeah.
Different.
I hear you though.
I hear it.
Like with Justin rent,
he's like,
dude,
coming to town doing rogue and I'll do yours after Mike.
If you're talking about kids and water in Africa for three hours in rogue and
you really don't need to do mine bro.
But he's Rafael Lovato.
Yeah,
I
got this.
Like I'm not,
you know,
we're contributing to his,
uh,
fight for the forgotten.
We're donating money and we're also a part of,
uh,
the cash app donates $5 every time someone signs up for the cash APP.
Um,
you use the promo code,
Joe Rogan all one word and the cash app sends you five bucks and the cash app
sends Justin Wren is fight for the forgotten.
That's cool,
man.
They've raised thousands of dollars.
Just doing that and building will's,
they've built two wells already during the process of building more you guys are
doing or you guys can do a benefit,
a comedy benefit.
I would do anything.
I'll help out.
I'll help it,
but he doesn't need come on my show to do.
If he didn't yell at him for three hours,
I'll do whatever you want.
What seem like make sure I don't forget his name.
It seemed like I was on the plane the other day,
man.
And this,
um,
I don't want mess up his name and be a dick head.
And uh,
oh Ray Borg.
Have you seen Ray Borg son?
No.
Son was sick babies having these surgeries and I saw someone post a shirt that
Ray Borg,
uh,
go to Ray Borg,
Instagram or Twitter and he puts his shirt,
he goes,
all these profe proceeds from the shirt go to help me pay for my child's medical
bill.
And so,
uh,
someone goes shop look into this.
And so I clicked on it.
Now I see you,
you know,
have a two and a half year old son.
I see a son on the the like the fricking Brader respirator broke my heart.
So I DM Tim and Ray,
I,
I'm sure bunch of people hit you up,
man.
There it is.
Idm Gray.
Cause that we need help with the medical bills.
I will pay for your medical bills.
Right?
I will cover it man.
So when I,
when I say I get emotional because I see a son,
when I say I'll help you re I'm dead serious man.
I'm not one of these guys who just,
I don't need the publicity.
I don't need any of that.
I sent you my idmg by number.
I will cover the medical pills,
man.
I got you brother.
I got you man.
Hit me up.
It's not a game.
It's no publicity.
I will take care of you,
you and your family.
That's it.
Well look,
you got all emotional dude.
When I see his kid on there man,
fucking kill you.
I know,
I know.
Just took me by surprise.
Sorry Dude.
I'm good now.
Do you know ray?
I don't know man.
I'll never met him.
Wow.
Never met him.
So how much money does he need to raise?
I don't know,
but I'm fucking rich.
I'm doing a show in Utah.
Donate all the money I make from my six shows.
And you told his medical bills.
Beautiful.
That's beautiful man.
Wiseguys St Louis.
October I think 10th through the 12th and one for her.
I think it's six shows.
I'll take all that money.
You can have it right.
That's beautiful.
That's a beautiful place to great place,
man.
Yeah.
Love,
love.
Utah does.
Does he not have medical insurance?
I don't know.
I don't think it covers it and he,
you know,
he's a broke fighter.
Yeah,
he's a broke fight or man and I just,
dude,
I'm so fortunate,
like me finding standup and I got so much cool stuff in the works and this
Bravo's show.
I'm like,
dude,
you just can't take,
take,
take.
I give to my family and all that.
I'm like,
I have to,
we have to figure some out here.
That's when I saw that.
I'm like,
what the fuck man.
That's awesome man.
I love that.
I love that about you.
Yeah,
lucky you.
I know.
I didn't mean to talk about and yeah,
I guess,
I don't know how we got brought up on that,
but I reached out to them and then I think he thought like,
Oh,
I'm sure I'm not going to donate it like $100 or something,
man.
Yeah.
Well maybe just was overwhelmed,
you know?
That's what I'm thinking.
That's why I'm,
I'm sure he listened to the show and I know he loves to buy on the kid and I
just thought of it now.
Well,
imagine the amount of time that it must be taking up too.
Not just trained,
but also to deal with the son and his son's medical issues and the family and
the bills and all the kids off.
Yeah.
I set up my son's stubs,
his toe,
my heart drops,
man.
Yeah,
it's hard.
Man.
Falls on the ground like funny.
Crazy.
Did you ever feel so vulnerable and you're,
oh my God,
I'm terrified of the world now.
Terrified.
I'll be driving my car.
I'm like,
Yo,
slow down there.
Do you think of people different now that you have a kid?
Do you hundred percent I'm way more.
I'm way more like I'm more scared of the world.
I feel like a more loving now.
I also,
if I have friends who are Shitty Dad,
I barely hang out with them anymore.
And the whole resent against cause I'm like that too.
That little dude need you so bad,
man.
Yeah.
Now I feel the same way.
Um,
you know,
the thing is like,
I feel sad for people who don't make the transition.
You know,
there's,
there's a transition to being a father that some people resist.
Yep.
Where it becomes the primary focus of your life,
it becomes a big,
big,
big deal.
But if you make that transition,
the love that comes out of that and the change that it brings about in you and
the benefits for your child there so substantial.
Ah,
I mean,
and it's so cliche.
It's the,
Oh,
it's the best thing I've ever done.
Straight up,
man.
I've had a cool fucking life.
It is by far the best thing I've ever done.
I want a squad I want,
because the love I get from that little dude,
I'm like,
three of you would be even cooler.
Yeah.
You're going to have more a hundred percent yeah.
Working on it right now.
Yup.
Hundred percent shooting live ones a try,
man.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
No,
this thing's working with whatever.
A fucking tail tail.
Yeah.
They say take zinc to take zinc and magnesium and I'm taking all these weird
pills.
It's now get that to get the load that come call you gotta save your loads too.
I know.
A big
day.
Yeah.
I went to a fertility clinic and they're all,
when's the last time you jacked off my girl?
Yeah.
I'm like,
damn,
Bro.
Like I don't damn dude.
I forget.
Never forget it.
I don't need to look at me Bro.
Dude.
I had to go get,
I had to go give them a sample and just see how,
you know how my,
how my guys are swimming.
Well,
first of all,
it's not,
it wasn't very professional at all.
They're like,
go just go down there was you grow with you when you had to give him a sample?
Yeah,
man.
Tell to help you now.
She was like busy talking to the guy in there.
She was like talking to the doctor and he's like,
he'll just take you the back.
I'm like,
alright.
Yeah,
so you had to jerk off knowing your girls and the other room too.
So I walk into this room,
it's just the Mexican dude just like,
hey man,
just go in there.
Don't touch anything,
just fill up the blank.
Gongos and Oh yeah,
the porn,
the porn is on hair.
They'll think you're old school TV.
V V v VCR like old school.
I'm like,
dude,
I don't need any of this.
I have a fucking cell phone.
Verda pornhub you fucking old dinosaur.
Fuck Outta here.
He goes,
we have magazines down there with 40 from the seventies kind of bacteria is
Marty and I know get the fuck out of here.
Other dudes,
loads and lube.
I'll take it from there.
Yeah.
How sterile and I would have been super shady.
He would have told my wife,
you're coming with me.
Do.
I felt like it was embarrassing to like ever like I'm like I can't,
I'm the thing in a bag and he just looks at it,
takes it out loads.
I'll do.
What if you opened it up and smell it now you could man.
He a lot of asparagus bro.
And then when you're walking back to see everyone knows that you're coming back.
You just get done Jack.
And we should walk up with your arms up in the air like you scored the winning
touchdown.
Yes.
Joy that.
Fuck yes.
But what happened?
This is my thing.
This is my,
and I went kind of down to Eddie Bravo conspiracy.
I'm like water for like damn your sperms.
Not good dude.
We get,
we're going to need more low.
Take your spring.
Take that to like,
he's a big babies.
Big Dude.
We're gonna use his genetics.
Make me sell that shit.
Black market.
There's a bunch of little browns running around.
You know what has happened many times more than once is these doctors,
if fertility clinics swap out,
other peoples come for their own and they have a bunch of their,
their own babies running around.
Like these people have wanted specific genetics and this one redheaded doctor
just shoot loads of the cups and then everybody's like,
hey,
why isn't my fucking kid have red hair?
The fuck?
Where's your revenue?
Nerdy man.
One doctor got arrested.
I think he fathered like a hundred children.
Oh my God.
Crazy,
crazy person or awesome back to the world.
I think he's just a crazy person because I stayed a seed.
Yeah,
he was running a sperm bank or a fertility clinic,
one of those and he just decided not.
It's going to be all me.
All my loads out there too.
Don't you think?
For like a retirement plan for these ads,
dude,
what does that image?
Oh,
okay.
It looks like cherish a bunch of these two accounts.
This does a bunch of these guys is not just one what?
1980 to 92 92 yeah.
No,
no.
I'm talking about like real resay the years in prison.
Oh yeah.
Shit.
He got to prison for that 280 years,
son,
280 years for jerking off.
Who could be seen to be saying,
oh dude,
don't you think you've very tired fighter,
let's say,
or athlete just in general.
Like Hershel Walker,
someone pay him $1 million for him to blow a load into a cup.
Did you ever watch the HBO,
uh,
Expo a on beat crumb from the beak from Yoga and all?
Yeah,
he was fucking,
he was here he is Indiana fertility doctor uses own sperm.
This is 2016 around 50 times papers say,
wow,
this is a recent guy.
I think there's been a bunch of these guys throughout history.
I think they should test every one of those guys.
They should make sure that they're not doing that.
Anybody running a fertility clinic and tickets,
it's like you get bored over and over again.
Guys are jacking off in the cops and you're like,
you know what?
Make my day.
I think if I take out this load and put it in my rent's 600 children,
there you go.
Wow.
Father had 600 children and own fertility clinic.
Repeatedly using his own sperm fertility clinic.
He ran.
Hey,
that's some sketchy shit,
man.
I'm telling you,
this is a normal thing.
Guys are gross.
Guys are men are gross.
Have a woman run that thing.
Women who were anti,
Amen.
Listen,
I swear to God,
we're not all like this,
but I get it.
I get it.
I really do get,
I talked about it in my special,
some creeps.
Yeah.
I mean I talked about it in this last special,
it's like I get it.
If I was a woman,
I'd be a feminist.
I get it.
Yeah,
we're fucking gross,
but not all of us.
Not all.
I would,
I would never jerk off into 600 cups of pretend it was someone else's load.
Never even crossed my mind.
It's not me,
but I know that there's guys like that out there that does not surprise me in
the slightest.
The FISA,
I'm fucking fat gross guy with a little tiny dick and some woman with this
banging ass and little tiny waist.
Big Old titties comes in and she's like,
you know,
we were just trying to get pregnant.
We're really struggling.
So we decided to go the sperm donor route like,
Hey,
yeah,
we got a super athlete and he's a genius.
Another guy,
he's a doctor.
Use Zones.
Bermed father 11 kids look at this guy.
Old Ass wigs were how old he is a song a week we had a broom head cheese.
Is that,
that might actually be his real hair.
No,
I me see another,
let me see.
No,
that's his hair man.
I don't feel lot back that back it up.
Back it up,
back it up.
Pause,
go full screen now you can.
You can get there bro.
I don't think so.
Dude.
Lets his hair that you can do get weeks like that dude bro.
That's his hair.
No crazy.
He's just got whacked care
a wig and get it all grave fucked up to 90 like why do you want a wig when you
just want your
head to be free?
It's trying to fund the office.
He has a problem that I see dudes with fucked up here and I just want to go up
to them and go,
listen to me man.
There's so much freedom and shaving your head.
Let it go.
Get me.
I've never been happier.
Shave your head.
It's easy for you.
If I,
if I had hair,
I'd shave it.
If I had hair.
If you had the set of here like you did in your twenties you would not say that.
I would absolutely get a crew cut.
I get it buzzed down to stem.
It shaped head nubs.
Yeah.
You had some nice hair,
man.
There's some get picked.
Barely.
It's an illusion.
It was going quick.
Most had thin hair.
Fine.
That's very fine.
They're not thick hairs,
you know?
But I swear,
even if I shaved my head the first time I shaved my head back when I was
fighting,
I was like,
uh,
so stupid.
I didn't want anybody to grab my hair.
That was my thought.
If you shave your head,
someone can't grab your hair.
So stupid.
But I was like 17 or 18 but I remember thinking like,
God,
this is so freeing.
It is nice.
Yeah.
You don't think about it.
You just wash and then go.
No,
there's no nothing,
but you got to style at squaw off.
You get a little sheet.
When I was fighting,
I didn't,
when I was fighting I shave it cause I remember I was getting ready for a
Jujitsu tournament and I was fixing my hair in the mirror and I was like,
what the fuck man,
how's this going to help?
I shaved it the next night.
That's good mood.
And I did that for my entire career until I retired.
And I'm like,
it's time to get my sex.
Yeah.
Whoo.
I agree with the shit out.
Ooh.
Yeah.
I can't pay you.
You don't want to have cauliflower ears and a shaved head like Bravo is not
hiring that guy.
May Bro.
Relax.
So Bravo hired you and uh,
are you liking it over there?
I do.
Like,
is that like working for Bravo?
I know.
I thought you were gonna make fun of me when they,
when uh,
g.
So Gerald Khan,
who's on the show with me,
he came,
he sold,
one of my sets,
came in the back and you and Brian were back then I was like compact to get
roasted by Rogan and fucking Cowen and you guys were so nice about it.
Why would I make fun of it?
So I thought it's a good gig.
It's a great gig.
I perfect free personalities,
make fun of shit original.
I didn't think it was a good Gig,
you know?
Um,
the guy who does,
or one of the producers who does below the belt on showtime,
Michael Davies at Mc row,
I was talking with him.
He goes,
Howard,
we're doing this a bravo show with Andy Cohen.
And he goes,
you watch bravo good all the time.
He has no,
you don't mean literally all the time.
Gimme gimme a question.
Name a show.
And he's like,
you really do it.
He goes,
do,
we're putting the show together,
you should audition for it.
And I was like,
I felt weird about it.
I talked to,
to my age and I'm like,
I don't know if that's for me,
man.
And he's just audition,
see what happens.
But then I went in there and did a chemistry test with Jl O'connell.
He's hilarious.
Oh,
Jerry O'Connell.
He came backstage.
Yeah.
See I didn't put the two together.
I didn't realize that he was backstage cause he was doing that thing.
Cherries was a very nice guy.
He's not,
and he's funny as hell.
And I thought,
all right,
this won't be too bad.
Like I know my real housewives,
but I was like,
how many of those shows do you watch?
Uh,
I watch real housewives of Orange County,
married the medicine,
Atlanta,
New York below deck.
My wife,
uh,
she,
she's been DVR and keeping up with the Kardashians and uh,
it was on the,
you know how when you turn on the TV,
it's already recording,
so it's playing.
So I sat there and as the show was on,
my jaw got more and more slack.
Look,
those look.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
Well,
eyelids get heavy and I just got,
she's got,
I'll send you out a fake ass
made me Tom.
My brain started drying out.
He's like changed a quick no,
you got to run.
I had to put on a deal de Grasse Tyson shot.
I've got to run quick on cosmos.
I think I like it for me because um,
you know,
fighting what I do when I cover fighting when I was playing,
it's so serious,
man.
That's how I got into that stuff.
I was like,
dude,
I just got done sparring Shane car one,
let me go home and eat a bag of Twizzlers and watch real housewives,
orange town and silliness fricking.
Here we are.
Sometimes it's fun when those bitches go off on each other.
They're so mean.
And you know,
the thing is like when the get them on camera and then they know they're on
camera so they try to be extra mean on camera.
Oh Dude.
Oh yeah.
They know exactly what they can just keeping it real.
I'm just being real bitch.
It'd be a real country.
I know.
It's cool seeing Jarrod Kahn who's been in the industry forever,
but then Andy Cohen who's a producer on it and then we had Kelly rip on the
show.
You just run in these like entertainment monsters,
like to see the way they work and like they're,
they're there for a reason.
Like you see Kelly rip unhealthy fast.
She is.
And like how she was professional.
She is,
she's like,
like she's a monster or Andy Cohen and puts all this together.
I go,
he's a monster and she'd still doing that show with Michael's tray hand.
She does it now with um,
Brian see Chris the same show.
Same show.
It's called Kelly and Ryan dray hand retired.
He went to good morning America and there was like a little bit of beef.
I don't know exactly why to have her and him.
She was like,
can't believe you're leaving.
And there's some weird beef I guess when I first gave her the beef.
I don't think so.
You might have though.
I bet he has a
big old fella.
Great football player too.
It seems like a real friendly guy.
Well to friendliness.
A little too good on the mic.
She charismatic dude.
He's amazing.
He made no attempt to fix that gap in his teeth.
Zero.
Kind of like that.
Me Too.
I saw Matt running one time.
He's zoomed up.
He fell.
He's a free fastest shit.
Yeah,
he's a super athlete.
You know what's amazing that a guy that's been playing that much football has
needs.
Like how's his niece to work?
I agree.
It's very strange what's going on there.
I'd like to get an Mri,
maybe got injected with some frickin stem cells and all the same things
do.
They fixed me the fuck up man and I still need to do,
I keep saying I'm going to do it.
My fucking right shoulder was so jacked and now it has,
it's like I don't have a problem with it at all.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Your whole body feels better.
Well they do it intravenously.
And when you did do it intravenously,
like takes care of little things and it takes care of things over a course of
like a few months like it like over one and two.
And by the way,
what I had done here in America is nothing in compared to what doctor Neil
Riordan is doing down in Panama with Tj Dillashaw went down there and that's why
Tj thanked him when he beat Cody and he won the title or defend the title gets
Cody.
And uh,
that's why Mel Gibson was on talking with Neil Riordan.
Everyone swears.
But Dude,
Mel Gibson's dad was 92 on death's door,
couldn't walk.
Now he's a hundred and walking around cat dam.
Yeah,
it's just,
they go there every few months,
every few months get jolted.
But what you do is,
it's not as good,
but it's similar.
Yeah.
Well,
they do it in America.
It's not,
it's not as extreme,
you know,
and they're doing tests on it.
It's called,
they're called exosomes.
Exosomes.
They used to think it was stem cells that were doing all the regenerative work,
but now they think that stem cells are releasing exosomes.
So now they just take exosomes and they put exosomes with platelet rich plasma
and they inject them directly into injuries and they've having,
they're having tremendous results to have tremendous results.
Dude,
I had a fucking full length rotator cuff take.
Huge problem gone.
I needed from her neck.
I need familiar cuff tear is gone.
It doesn't exist anymore.
I got a new MRI.
There's no more tear.
That's fucking magic.
That's the magic.
You should have to have surgery.
Yes,
I was gonna.
I was,
I was trying to put it off.
That's what I was trying to do.
I was like,
eventually I'm going to have to have surgery now.
I'm like,
I don't need surgery.
I just need it from my neck.
What's going on with your neck?
It got injured when uh,
during the Travis Browne camp and then in my last fight when,
which is four years ago,
which is crazy thing about for long,
four years ago when I went to go take down Travis,
all his weight,
he sprawled and landed on my neck.
And if you look at the tape,
my neck folds like this with his hips on top of me.
I shared this in my neck and ever since then it's been fucking,
just not great.
Did you ever get an Mri?
I got one a while ago and there's,
there's one of the,
what do you call them?
One of the things are dead.
One of the,
one of your disks.
This is like black.
Black.
Yeah.
I guess one of the discs,
there's an issue with the one that disk,
Ooh,
I know black.
Yeah.
What's that about?
I don't know.
They don't know what that means.
They did.
This was a while ago.
I should do it again.
That was right after the funders should do it again.
After the podcast.
We'll talk cause a,
I'll send you to a,
my doctor I just said and Kenny Florian down there.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I could use it.
Yeah,
they're doing well.
The one of the things they do for dis that dude,
they do stem cells as well,
but they also do something called Regina King.
That's the thing that Coby Bryan and Peyton Manning,
they were going to Germany to get done and now they do it in America.
They've been doing in America for quite a while now.
That's what fixed my neck when I had a bulging discs in my neck and my hand is
going numb.
Regena cane fix me and need you saw I sneak yet.
I just got to make it a priority.
Yeah.
Just I'm so,
I've been so busy I haven't been able to stop.
It's nice though.
Yeah.
Look at you out there hustling.
Hustling.
A little Birdie told me you got to show time special coming out.
Got a comedy special coming on January.
Shit.
They get a film in January or it's going to come out and just filming it.
The [inaudible] theater in San Diego.
Oh
Shit.
What day?
Big Boy right now.
I think it's on the 27th.
How many uh,
shows you filming too.
Nice.
That's good.
I know for his ideal it's ideal to two's good?
Yup.
It's that that Saturday is the 20 or no,
that's a 26.
26th you in town.
So I am now Shab special a you be special.
I am son.
Big Boy moves.
Yeah.
Alright,
moving right.
San Diego there.
Okay.
Locations.
San Diego.
Yeah.
Big Boy moves,
man.
Do you feel weird about filming something you,
you,
you feel pumped about that super pumped about it?
I,
uh,
super pumped but super excited about it.
I know the product,
the qualities,
you'd be great.
I guess for me it's more of like,
like I told you,
you're the first person I told,
but I,
uh,
like I wouldn't go to the comedy store and like be like,
Yo,
what's up dude?
Doing economy,
you know,
like I just,
I feel weird around other comics because I feel like they're gonna judge me.
Like,
what the fuck?
You know,
it's not that listen to them,
I just don't,
I feel like if maybe there's comics who've been doing it for 10 years and they
have no big time special or,
you know,
it's like,
I don't want them to hold resentment toward not that can deal with any of that,
but that's why I don't share it with everyone.
Well,
I tell comics the difference between you and them is it,
you have a professional athlete's work ethic and comics have very little work
ethic.
Yeah.
They're lazy as fuck.
That's the number one problem.
If you'd say,
what's the number one problem with comics jerking off in front of women?
Number two,
lazy.
And I'd say number three just self sabotage like that.
A lot of comics I see doing the same material over and over.
I'm like,
well that,
listen Meagan,
a special on showtime doesn't take anything away from you.
It's good level playing field.
They give out a ton.
Just because,
uh,
Chris Delea got a special on Netflix doesn't mean they took it away from you.
Right?
There's room for everybody.
There's either you're just not funny or you're not putting in the work.
I have nothing to do with it or,
yeah,
I mean guys don't like to edit either.
That's another problem.
They don't like to chop their things down and boil them and make them better.
You know,
they have a bit,
they,
they say it a certain way and they like to say it that way.
Forever.
Can't do that.
No.
Comedy is a living thing.
It's like a living art form.
It's constantly changing and evolving.
Like I had a friend come to see me and then they came to see me for months and
be like,
dude,
that fucking bit is totally different.
I'm like,
yeah,
you got to tweak it.
Yep.
Got It.
Always be tweaking.
I think don't,
the only way for me to tweak is doing on stage.
I can,
I ride it out different,
but I only find it on state 100% so I have to do those full weekends.
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
That's where it's at.
Two,
two,
two and just roll.
Yeah.
I find that even with theaters when I'm doing two theaters at night,
I get more done than just one like one on one of the things about these big
places,
you just doing one show.
Yeah,
you're better off.
You're really better off.
Like one of the things I'm looking forward to is somewhere around December I'm
going to start booking clubs and I'm going to,
you
know,
I'll do like Oxnard.
I'll do like levity live in Oxnard.
I'll do like the comedy works in Denver lives.
Yeah.
I'll do some s maybe even the punchline.
San Francisco,
even smart Sacramento.
You mean?
Uh,
San Francisco too.
Is there a pendulum?
Isn't there punch?
I'm doing punchline in Sacramento and that's great too.
That's a great little Gig,
but it's near a lot of cracked out people.
I,
it's a been there.
I've been there before.
Men,
that parking lot sketch,
I stay far away.
Drive me.
Yeah,
that parking lot.
Sketch sketchy.
Yeah.
Red Van.
I almost got killed.
She in the hotel,
she says subscribed.
I don't stay at the normal.
Yeah,
the parking lot.
Sketchy.
But the club's awesome.
So you can start doing much more clubs.
That's the deal you do.
You know,
you have to have those four set weekends,
five set weekends where he just,
you know,
like you'll have a bit that you come in on Thursday and then by the time
Saturday rolls around,
that bit's alive.
It's cracking.
Yup.
You know,
but it's also one of the great things about being able to work so much in La.
Like Thursday night I did four sets.
A Tuesday night or three sets.
No,
I did three of the store and one the Improv.
Jesus.
Yeah.
I did two main room shows.
I had my show in the main room I did were stone show in the main room and then I
did a the or,
and then before that I did a show at the Improv.
I liked the Improv.
Improv is not bad man.
You know,
now that they pushed that fucking piano keys,
the way Jesus stepped piano was stupid.
Like how many people use that fucking piano that you're blocking?
Half the stage.
Just Brian Killen does he use it?
He would get on their neck like he's playing the piano was hilarious,
but not anymore.
Brian.
They got rid of it.
Sorry Brian.
So I'd be,
yeah,
I mean who would use it?
Chris Robinson.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's it.
It's just the old school thing to do.
Well,
yeah,
it's like,
I think it's like a witty thing to have around like how many people will have a
piano in their house actually play the piano.
What a Dick move.
Have Piano in your house.
Especially if you have the back part.
Opal.
I know like your Mozart or some shit.
Like you know,
fucking run a whole,
I wish I could play the piano.
Be honest with you.
I'd have people over and play it.
Would you interrupt the Superbowl?
Fucking pause.
We're to take a moment and I'm going to fucking,
I will now call him champ though to put your pizza down.
Yeah.
We're going to drink white wine and I'm going to play the piano.
Just just take move ever.
Do you ever think you'd get to the point where you're so pretentious,
you're willing to go to a musical,
a musical opera?
I'll go to some musicals,
Bro,
and I went to Hamilton by myself in New York like a psycho.
Why'd you and I left her like,
why'd you do that?
I like plays and theater.
I went to see Annie at the Hollywood bowl.
Is it good?
Nope.
You took your kids?
Yup.
Yeah.
It wasn't good.
You don't like that stuff though?
Nope.
See I like that stuff.
I was thinking about all sorts of other things going over my act while it was
happening,
I couldn't enjoy it.
I was so bored.
I know the story.
That's part of the problem that it's like going to see King Kong,
Hey,
guess King Kong dies the
end.
You Fuck Spiderman two over.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
we know the story.
Yeah,
Spiderman is going to live.
He's going to become Spiderman.
I mean maybe that's impossible.
Twists and turns if they're going to Redo it,
but at the end of the day,
King Kong dies.
True.
And Annie,
they didn't change at a God damn word where your kids loving it or they were
like,
no,
there should a board too.
That's a problem.
But you know,
it's a fun what?
Well,
this might be too.
I don't,
how old are your kids?
Eight and 10.
The little nightmare before Christmas live there.
We've Sandy Elfman gums that she'd done that dope.
That was good because the last years have grown man.
They also play,
they have music,
but they also play the movie.
But they have the actual character,
the girl,
the lady from home alone.
The mom.
Yeah,
she's the voice.
Danny Elfman.
Danny Elfman has that big Dick Energy,
doesn't,
he just rolls up there like you don't give a fuck.
And he's just had Scientology.
Scientology.
Yeah.
Let's get that Tom Cruise energy.
Wow,
bro.
That Wilson word energy.
It does.
Where they ship energy,
Bro.
That's
a new one.
It doesn't seem to bother them.
That's hilarious.
That's a good show though.
But I went to Hamilton.
I had no idea.
I was just,
I was there for a night of shooting that Bravo's show.
I'm all by myself when he got a nice proper meal.
So you did this recent one.
It's like three weeks ago.
Dude.
She got a proper meal by yourself all by myself.
Got The prime rib.
Just soared the prime rib.
Very Kido ate by myself.
Expensive little mail,
like whatever.
See Ya went online but a not a cheap ticket to Hamilton sat there and was like,
Yo,
this is cool.
[inaudible] decided to do this because you're on Bravo.
Let me do some other gay things,
man.
Just trying to live bro.
Trying to embrace the New York vibe.
Broadway live.
Okay.
Everyone's been talking about Hamilton forever.
Are they really?
I mean,
talking to the Ted talk of the town is the first time I been winning in front of
me has ever talked about
literally maybe my circles,
Bro.
I just feel like it was a big deal.
So I get there,
right?
And I'm like,
all right,
this could be cool.
And uh,
they wrap the entire time.
And so an hour and a half goes by.
I'm like,
oh,
that was fun and we go to get up.
I'm like,
well that was,
that was good.
And the guy's like,
that's intermission.
There's another hour and a half.
I'm like,
no fucking way.
So I thought,
you know what?
Let's not waste money.
I don't want to disrespect the town and let's just sit down.
So I sat down,
started get back up,
this fat do started to sing and went,
you know what,
I'm fucking out of here.
And I walked out and has something to hear the guy working goes,
he knew me cause Shab who leaves early?
Who?
Hampton earlier when I do and just fucking got out.
It's like,
dude,
I can't do it,
man.
When I was 18 years old,
I was dating this girl and she took me to see cats.
That's an old school one.
Yeah.
It's not your thing.
It was a murderous assault on my attention.
They're tough.
They're crawling around like I'm a cat.
Ah,
ah,
ah.
Ah.
It is the worst piece of shit.
I couldn't believe how bad it had a great thing.
He goes,
can we stop pretending you're in the fucking,
it's the Thomas Jefferson.
He goes,
what the fuck is this?
Why are you guys acting like you're in the middle
of a fucking war zone?
You're on a fucking stage.
I was laughing so hard because that's his background.
Cats.
No.
In a war zone or hammer.
No,
no.
Hamilton.
All these.
Look at this.
Look how bad.
This is.
Rare.
I'm a cat.
She must have been the hottest girl ever to get you to go to this thing.
She was,
hey,
I'll put,
I'll put up with some shit.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean she was chats in a dick too.
We were both 18 and we're both like,
maybe this is what adults do.
Yeah.
Cool.
Dude,
this was good.
Pretend to be adults and then you were bored.
It was she board of,
she all into it was just like,
sorry,
my bad.
I mean,
she had never been before.
It was one of those things.
You know,
you,
you hear like look,
go,
look,
we'll,
we're going on a date.
Let's go to a musical.
Okay.
Yeah,
let's go see Cassie.
I'm not,
I've never been there.
I won't ride it out on and be like,
oh,
let's just get through this.
Even if a movie,
a movie,
if it's boring,
I'm out,
man.
I found,
see Ya.
Good for you.
See them.
You gotta be able to do that.
God,
it just pull the tree like this sucks.
Right?
Torture in you the worst.
The absolute worst one.
Last time you started good movie.
What's the last good movie you've seen?
God with the Kiddo.
It's stuffed to go to the movies.
I like the little feet.
You gotta to take your kid to sleep this week.
Have you seen it?
No.
I want us.
Good.
Hell yeah.
Lebron James,
isn't it?
That's a lot of people say that's the first sign.
They knew that he was gonna go to the Lakers for sure.
What?
He's going to movies.
He's Hollywood.
He's going Hollywood.
I,
I've been watching a bunch of shows on like Netflix.
I kept seeing sinner or Jessica Biel.
No,
it's amazing.
Really good.
She should have won that Goddamn Emmy.
What does that an encore show or something like there's on USA.
It was on USA and they brought over to Netflix.
That shit.
Yeah,
it's on Netflix and it is straight up.
It's intense.
The first episode,
like what the fuck?
Yeah.
That's a damn good.
Hmm.
I haven't seen a good movie in a long time.
You Watch Ozark?
No,
I watch first one.
Couldn't get into it.
People I know.
I know.
People need to what?
I know what,
what I know Bro.
People love it.
They're on season two,
right?
I'm on season two,
episode nine and he loves it.
Oh.
If I get a show I like,
I will just fucking power through that thing.
It's a good show,
man.
I'm telling you.
Give it a chance.
Yeah.
You got to get on it.
It keeps getting pissed.
Second person told me no,
it's fucking good.
What about strange times or stranger things?
Stranger things,
strange stranger things.
Have you seen that?
You've seen that,
right?
Yeah,
it's good.
It's amazing.
They're doing season three now.
This is the best time ever to be a lazy fuck and just sit in front of the TV.
There's more sugar content and it sounded like the contents going away.
That's what's really crazy,
dude.
I'd laugh at shows like I'll,
I'll watch good more and make or something in the morning.
It's been when,
when commercials hit,
I laugh.
I'm like,
you silly fucked as chasse channel.
What is like,
what are you doing?
I'm just gonna go to something else I'm not seeing with this radio.
I know.
It's so old school commercials.
Yeah.
Interrupting them.
I get mad when people do commercials in the middle of the podcasts.
Do you do commercials in the middle of Your podcast?
We do.
I do them all up front.
That's right.
It,
I'm all up
front.
That's how you do it.
I mean offset.
I've learned from you.
Yeah.
Fuck all that interrupting.
I think people get upset and they'd rather not buy.
I think if people were inclined they like,
you know a Chubb,
I'll try the Squarespace shit out because you advertise it in front of your pod.
Fuck up bro.
Yeah.
We've had some I'm looking at,
we've had some that asked for mid roll,
but it's very rare you just all up,
everything's up front.
Yeah.
Everything's a way to do it.
Everything.
Even with FM radio,
like I'd go into certain cities and I just had this conversation with my age.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm not doing press anymore.
Yeah.
Not doing press cause all sorts of different animal for me because these big
sport FM radio station and bring me on comic writer could be break it down like
I got my own show bitch trying to showtime sternum below the belt,
my podcast,
listen to that.
That me breakdown Conor,
Khabib not selling any comedy tickets going to talk about you want to talk about
just life.
I'm down.
You want me to break down the fucking Broncos game or it could be common.
It's not happening.
Well.
It's also a problem with if you're lucky,
your personality goes well with them,
but I've had many in during my days of doing the road and doing radio,
I've had many times where I just did not vibe with the person who was the DJ and
it all a real issue and then you come off as a dick,
like some things I'd be like,
no,
I don't want to talk about that.
Like y'all talking about,
no,
I don't talk about an ex girlfriend.
He want talk.
My next girlfriend like we didn't doing man.
Like what are you doing?
Like you just try to make things controversial because you're not interesting
or,
or what would make him comfortable?
Oh Dude,
you and Dana White.
What's the deal there?
I'm like,
no deal.
What do you mean?
What do you want?
How am I gonna make this and sell Cami tickets?
Right.
How's that going to work,
dude?
Wow.
It's just they're not that good.
No radio.
There's a lot of people out there doing it.
They're just not that good at I shop when I was doing it when I was doing radio,
I'd be like,
you're just not an interesting person.
No,
you're,
you're like noise in between people that are talking that are interesting to
your interviewing in between music and you have a giant ego.
Yup.
Huge.
They have to pick a seat goes I,
yeah.
And also like,
it's so old school to move tickets.
It just,
it doesn't make sense to me.
Well,
you know,
it's more old school and more gross.
Those morning TV shows.
Good Morning Dallas.
We're here with Brendan Shaw from the Ufo
to talk about knuckle fighting or something.
What did through,
I did one in Spokane and this is the last letter that I was like,
oh,
I'm out.
There's no more.
I'm never doing this again.
Ah,
here we are with Brennan Schwab,
Brendan UFC,
NFL comedy.
Where do you stop real quick,
how about the weather?
And had me read though,
and I went,
what?
And they go the route you want to do.
Take the weather from heroin.
Uh,
I've lived on it.
I'm like,
you want me to breach or whether we stick your butt out like that one.
Uh,
Mexican chick with a giant ass.
If you ever seen her.
Oh,
in the,
in the Mexico dude.
Who?
She
makes me sweat.
I would read her while she Mexican or South American.
I forget.
This is Max skin.
Oh,
mine too.
She is.
See,
that's different.
I would do that for you.
Jerk off into a cup.
Here she is.
Look at her.
Oh my God.
Look at what she's wearing.
Almost nothing to Udi.
Look at that booty.
They can't help but stare at Garcia.
What is her name?
Mexican Garcia.
Break the Internet.
Oh my God.
Her body is off the charts,
but a tool to they're doing it fucking right,
aren't they?
Yeah.
That's how you do it.
I mean who gives a fuck if she knows anything?
Who you know?
Who knows?
Who knows what's going on?
Three,
3 million of loud ass.
That is a blowout ass too.
Perfect.
Perfect body.
Look at her.
Look at her in her underwear.
Oh my God.
But she is gorgeous.
It's pretty God damn hot.
See now that makes sense.
It we should do is go out there and get down your underwear.
It's take your ass and need do some shows in Mexico.
It sounds,
I can do some press there.
I said no press.
Oh correct.
And that's sounding the exams again,
whether I'm just here to do the weather.
Only here a talk about cloud.
She was a,
she just broke up with a pro gamer call of duty.
Oh,
so was single.
Huh?
She was dating a nerd.
That's amazing.
Rich nerds.
Nerds are coming up.
Rich nerd.
Those call of duty nerds are coming up.
Those video game was just heard about her recently for some reason and that's
what it was.
Pro gamers might as well be golfers now,
right,
to get paid.
Yeah,
right.
They might as well be golfers money damn.
And you tubers like right.
Like just straight youtubers.
A lot of them stupid money.
Hey,
no major network.
Nothing.
If you say,
if he s a fricking Logan,
Paul,
come on,
good morning America.
He's like socket flat her to uh,
work on call of duty.
He what dumped her to work on his call of duty.
You see this kid,
she wanted too much.
Dick.
I,
he's a handsome fella.
Handsome Fella.
He might have him us in the world.
Out Booty.
Yeah,
like other Dick.
How does he like pass up on her?
Just let her ride it while you playing the game.
Maybe she's terrible in bed though and he's like,
that's not even physically possible.
You know what?
You're right.
That's nine.
There's a bad Porsche to drive.
It's just now they're not all great.
Can fix it up.
There we go.
Oh Jesus Christ.
That's the two of them together and he broke up with her too.
I'm confused.
Is he ended cock.
He must.
There must be something wrong with his brain.
Look at him.
He's Jack though.
Dude.
He's,
he's probably nasty on the stakes.
Could googly mooglie today.
I would give lower all.
I'll get that.
Good Lord.
The body and that lady did.
He dumped her.
I was like,
move on bitch.
Listen man,
those guys are coming up breaking news.
I'm out.
Pro gamers coming up in this world too,
and apparently it's a different life.
Drop some breaking news on her eyes.
Get tired of that one.
Just like there's someone out there and say,
you know what I'm saying?
That's what I'm saying,
Jay Z.
That's what I heard.
But there's,
you know,
people get sick of it.
If you like it,
then you should've put a ring on it.
Oh,
uh,
oh.
Uh,
any other fights?
Talk about we done.
I think we're done.
Thank Rick Don brother.
We covered it all.
When is the fucking next fight companion?
Let's figure that out.
Jamie,
pull up to you.
Figure it out.
Schedule.
I'm on the road damn near every weekend,
but let's figure it out.
What do we got,
Jamie?
Okay.
Bom Bom,
Bom Bom Bom bom seventh.
Uh,
the 10 wait a minute.
October 27th might be a possibility.
Thank you.
Had Korean Zombie on November 10.
Hold on.
October 27th.
Um,
Volcong owes Demir versus a Johnson Right Click on that.
Anthony.
Anthony Smith Rather.
Why does,
I was going to say Anthony does,
is that you said that's the 27th.
Yeah.
I'm in Phoenix with your boy.
Rem,
big j doing a show at unseal and Brian a bitch sounds like better.
It sounds like more fun.
You should come with us.
Which sharp?
Good.
Wait a minute.
What is the Denver one?
The Denver one is cowboy versus Mike Perry too.
That's a motherfucking,
that's November 10th.
We'll should,
what are you doing there?
Let me see.
No fabric.
Oh,
I'm in.
I'm in town.
That's it.
Fight companion.
I'm putting it in right now.
Alright.
Campaign companion.
Put it in my calendar too.
That's a scary one for,
uh,
for cowboy.
That's a fun fight for everything on this car.
Benevidez Ray Boggs on that card.
Cowboy Mike Perry,
Koreans,
uh,
Zombie versus Frankie Edgar's team.
All diamond pieces and Yoda versus Cooper.
Oh,
well look at this.
Raquel Pang to returns against Jermaine.
Jermaine Duran to me,
she's like,
Yay.
Fuck all that.
145 pound title.
She said,
fuck your toilet.
Fight on the undercard.
What does the a dime piece one,
a Yoda.
Rich Cooper.
Now the UFC pictures aren't flattering,
but if you look at their answers,
you see 'em damn five Kenzie,
Darren made a video for Joey Dee is saint.
She's going to kick his ass after all.
She was joking though,
smelling her ass.
All the joking.
She's hilarious.
Yeah.
[inaudible] dare you Sean,
that card too.
That's a good card,
man.
Fight companion.
My companion.
Denver.
It's in that realignment.
Yup.
All right.
That's it.
Um,
[inaudible] k.com.
I'm at Salt Lake City.
That is October 10th through the 12th and after that I'm in San Francisco.
COBB's after that,
Sacramento.
Whoa.
Dot Cobb five k.com.
Thanks,
brother.
Thanks brother.
Bye everybody.
Oh,
we'll be right back with Rhonda.
Patrick.
Hmm.